programming throwdown episode 95 web rtc with sean dubois take it away jason hey everybody we have uh sean here on the show and we're going to be talking a lot about WebRTC, which is something many of you might have never even heard of, but it's really eye-opening. It's kind of a shocking thing to find out. It's kind of opening Pandora's box. And so how are you doing, Sean? Would you like to sort of introduce yourself? Great.
programming throwdown episode 95 web rtc with sean dubois take it away jason hey everybody we have uh sean here on the show and we're going to be talking a lot about WebRTC, which is something many of you might have never even heard of, but it's really eye-opening. It's kind of a shocking thing to find out. It's kind of opening Pandora's box. And so how are you doing, Sean? Would you like to sort of introduce yourself? Great.|||programming throwdown 第 95 期，本期节目我们请来了 Sean Dubois 来聊聊 WebRTC。把时间交给你，Jason。大家好，我们今天请到了 Sean 来到节目中，我们要深入探讨 WebRTC。这可能很多人甚至都没听过，但它真的让人大开眼界。了解之后会觉得挺震撼的，就像是打开了潘多拉的魔盒。那么 Sean，你最近怎么样？要不要简单做个自我介绍？太好了。
Yeah, thanks for having me on. So I am Sean. I work on the Pyon project, which is a Go implementation of WebRTC, which is sort of like a nebulous thing. So I guess we'll spend the next hour unpacking. But yeah, so I work in like the WebRTC space. I've sort of gone through a bunch of different weird things.
Yeah, thanks for having me on. So I am Sean. I work on the Pyon project, which is a Go implementation of WebRTC, which is sort of like a nebulous thing. So I guess we'll spend the next hour unpacking. But yeah, so I work in like the WebRTC space. I've sort of gone through a bunch of different weird things.|||好的，谢谢邀请我来。我是 Sean。我参与了 Pyon 项目，这是一个用 Go 语言实现的 WebRTC 项目。WebRTC 这个概念听起来有点模糊，所以我想我们会在接下来的一个小时里好好剖析一下。总之，我从事 WebRTC 领域的工作，之前经历过各种各样奇怪的事情。
I started out in the VoIP and phone industry, found my way working on PHP, and then sort of ended up here. And it's been a fun ride. Cool. So you worked on the PHP interpreter itself or writing PHP? Yeah. So I was hired at Etsy. And originally I started out doing JavaScript and LAMP development. And they gave me an opportunity to write C and work on PHP itself. So I added, I think, visibility operators
I started out in the VoIP and phone industry, found my way working on PHP, and then sort of ended up here. And it's been a fun ride. Cool. So you worked on the PHP interpreter itself or writing PHP? Yeah. So I was hired at Etsy. And originally I started out doing JavaScript and LAMP development. And they gave me an opportunity to write C and work on PHP itself. So I added, I think, visibility operators|||我最早是从事 VoIP 和电话行业的，后来阴差阳错开始做 PHP，然后就来到了这里。这段经历挺有意思的。酷。那你当时是从事 PHP 解释器本身的开发，还是用 PHP 写代码？是的。我当时受雇于 Etsy。最初我做的是 JavaScript 和 LAMP 开发。后来他们给了我一个用 C 语言编写代码并参与 PHP 本身开发的机会。所以，我添加了，我想是可见性运算符，
to class constants, and I ported a bunch of extensions from PHP to PHP 7, like the ones written in C. Whoa, that's amazing. So how do you get started doing something like that? Because it seems like languages themselves are just enormous projects. And it seems very difficult to amend a language.
to class constants, and I ported a bunch of extensions from PHP to PHP 7, like the ones written in C. Whoa, that's amazing. So how do you get started doing something like that? Because it seems like languages themselves are just enormous projects. And it seems very difficult to amend a language.|||给类常量添加了可见性，并且把一堆扩展从旧版 PHP 移植到了 PHP 7，比如那些用 C 语言编写的扩展。哇，太厉害了。那你当初是怎么开始做这种事的呢？因为编程语言本身似乎就是巨大的项目，修改一门语言看起来非常困难。
How do you get started in that? How do you get your changes approved? How does all that work? So I got really, really lucky. The company Etsy, they're the ones that really kick-started my career. That was the first job in the industry. So I got really lucky with the mentorship they provided. And I think the easiest thing to do is jump in
How do you get started in that? How do you get your changes approved? How does all that work? So I got really, really lucky. The company Etsy, they're the ones that really kick-started my career. That was the first job in the industry. So I got really lucky with the mentorship they provided. And I think the easiest thing to do is jump in|||你是如何着手去做这件事的？你的修改又是如何获得批准的？这一切是怎么运作的？我真的非常非常幸运。Etsy 这家公司真正开启了我的职业生涯，那是我在行业内的第一份工作。所以我在他们提供的指导下感到非常幸运。我觉得最简单的方法就是直接上手，
and make little changes that are supported by unit tests. It's so easy to get things approved by open-source maintainers. If you can jump in and make a change and the build's green, it's very likely they're going to accept it. So that's how I got lucky. I just went in, and I think the first one was IG binary or something. It was like a compression format. And the nice thing is if I can port it from PHP 5 to 7
and make little changes that are supported by unit tests. It's so easy to get things approved by open-source maintainers. If you can jump in and make a change and the build's green, it's very likely they'll accept it. So that's how I got lucky. I just went in, and I think the first one was IG binary or something. It was like a compression format. And the nice thing is if I can port it from PHP 5 to 7|||然后做一些有单元测试支持的小改动。要让开源维护者批准你的改动其实很简单。如果你能直接参与并做出修改，而且构建测试都通过了（绿灯），他们极大概率会接受它。这就是我幸运的地方。我直接进去了，我记得第一个项目是 IG binary 还是什么的，它是一种压缩格式。好消息是，如果我能把它从 PHP 5 移植到 7，
and all the test paths, it just got merged, which made it really easy. Wow, that's awesome. And then is the documentation auto-generated or you have to write that as well? Oh, so the lucky thing is that there was no documentation changes since we were just moving versions of the language. So just like API change and little things like they went from a bunch of heap allocations to stack allocations because of the way the PHP VM was changing. So it made it really easy.
and all the test paths, it just got merged, which made it really easy. Wow, that's awesome. And then is the documentation auto-generated or you have to write that as well? Oh, so the lucky thing is that there was no documentation changes since we were just moving versions of the language. So just like API change and little things like they went from a bunch of heap allocations to stack allocations because of the way the PHP VM was changing. So it made it really easy.|||并且所有的测试都通过了，它就会被合并，这让整个过程变得非常简单。哇，太棒了。那么文档是自动生成的，还是你也必须自己写？哦，幸运的是，由于我们只是迁移语言的版本，所以不需要修改文档。仅仅是一些 API 的变动和小调整，比如由于 PHP 虚拟机（VM）的改变，它们从堆分配转向了栈分配。这让事情变得非常简单。
Wow, very cool. Yeah, yeah, I think people will love to pick your brain on that. At the end of the show, we'll give away for people to reach out to you. Yeah, so that's fascinating. So coming back to WebRTC, so basically what is WebRTC? And at a high level, what does it do for people? At a high level, I think the first thing that people will jump in is they'll build a project and they'll think,
Wow, very cool. Yeah, yeah, I think people will love to pick your brain on that. At the end of the show, we'll give away for people to reach out to you. Yeah, so that's fascinating. So coming back to WebRTC, so basically what is WebRTC? And at a high level, what does it do for people? At a high level, I think the first thing that people will jump in is they'll build a project and they'll think,|||哇，太酷了。对，我觉得大家一定会很想听听你在这方面的见解。在节目快结束时，我们会告诉大家如何联系到你。好的，这太吸引人了。那么回到 WebRTC，基本上来说，WebRTC 是什么？从宏观层面上讲，它能为人们做些什么？从宏观层面来看，人们刚接触时做的第一件事往往是构建一个项目，然后心想：
oh, I want to get my webcam from one browser to another. And you'll get that going and it'll be great and you'll be excited and you'll see it. But what I like to think about it as is think about how do I get something from computer A to computer B without any servers in the middle, sort of that promise of like peer-to-peer. So instead of paying all these server costs of sending media or data to a server and then back to their client, you just have these two computers
oh, I want to get my webcam from one browser to another. And you'll get that going and it'll be great and you'll be excited and you'll see it. But what I like to think about it as is think about how do I get something from computer A to computer B without any servers in the middle, sort of that promise of like peer-to-peer. So instead of paying all these server costs of sending media or data to a server and then back to their client, you just have these two computers|||“哦，我想把我的网络摄像头画面从一个浏览器传到另一个浏览器。”你会把它跑通，这会很棒，你会感到兴奋，并亲眼看到效果。但我更愿意这样去理解它：思考如何将某些东西从计算机 A 传输到计算机 B，而中间没有任何服务器，这就是点对点（P2P）的承诺。因此，你不需要支付将媒体或数据发送到服务器然后再返回客户端的各种服务器成本，而是让这两台计算机
talk directly to each other. And then it really expands way out beyond just conferencing. You have to think about all these different products that we're seeing coming out. So the ones that really excite me is Google Stadia is using WebRTC, which is they're using it to do the game streaming, which is really cool. So they're sending video frames from a remote server down to you. So instead of running a video game locally, you're running it in a super powerful computer out in a data center somewhere you've got things like mixer.com that are doing super low latency game streaming so instead of um you know it's actually fast enough that people are mutating the game state by pressing buttons in their browser and that's how fast it is it feels real time so it's just that promise to have low latency
talk directly to each other. And then it really expands way out beyond just conferencing. You have to think about all these different products that we're seeing coming out. So the ones that really excite me is Google Stadia is using WebRTC, which is they're using it to do the game streaming, which is really cool. So they're sending video frames from a remote server down to you. So instead of running a video game locally, you're running it in a super powerful computer out in a data center somewhere you've got things like mixer.com that are doing super low latency game streaming so instead of um you know it's actually fast enough that people are mutating the game state by pressing buttons in their browser and that's how fast it is it feels real time so it's just that promise to have low latency|||直接进行通信。然后，它的应用范围远远超出了会议的范畴。你必须想想我们现在看到的各种涌现出的不同产品。真正让我兴奋的是，Google Stadia 正在使用 WebRTC 来做游戏串流，这真的非常酷。它们将视频帧从远程服务器发送给你。因此，你不是在本地运行视频游戏，而是在某个数据中心里一台超级强大的计算机上运行它。你还有像 mixer.com 这样的服务，它们在做超低延迟的游戏串流。所以，你知道的，它的速度实际上快到人们可以通过在浏览器中按按钮来改变游戏状态，就是这么快，感觉就像是实时的。所以这就是低延迟的承诺——
communication between two people directly instead of using a server. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So a lot of people listening might not know kind of what happens. So let's take, let's say, Google Hangouts. So Google Hangouts is client server. When you call somebody, the data goes kind of to Google server and then from Google server to somebody else. And that seems intuitive. Most people can understand that there's
communication between two people directly instead of using a server. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So a lot of people listening might not know kind of what happens. So let's take, let's say, Google Hangouts. So Google Hangouts is client server. When you call somebody, the data goes kind of to Google server and then from Google server to somebody else. And that seems intuitive. Most people can understand that there's|||让两个人直接进行通信，而不需要使用服务器。是的，这完全说得通。所以很多听众可能不太清楚幕后到底发生了什么。那么我们以 Google Hangouts 为例。Google Hangouts 是客户端-服务器（C/S）架构的。当你给某人打电话时，数据会先发到 Google 的服务器，然后从 Google 的服务器再发给其他人。这似乎很直观。大多数人都能理解，
some huge data center somewhere, probably like in the heartland or some rural area, and electrons, or in this case, particles of light, I guess, if you have optic, are traveling from your computer um over to that data center and over to that other person's computer and it kind of makes sense for both you to be connected to google right but how does that translate to something like this where um you know you're on wi-fi in your house someone's on wi-fi in their house in a totally different state
some huge data center somewhere, probably like in the heartland or some rural area, and electrons, or in this case, particles of light, I guess, if you have optic, are traveling from your computer um over to that data center and over to that other person's computer and it kind of makes sense for both you to be connected to google right but how does that translate to something like this where um you know you're on wi-fi in your house someone's on wi-fi in their house in a totally different state|||在某个地方有一个巨大的数据中心，可能在心脏地带或某个乡村地区，电子——或者在这个例子中，如果你有光纤的话，就是光粒子——正从你的计算机出发，传到那个数据中心，再传到另一个人的计算机。你们俩都连接到 Google，这似乎说得通，对吧？但是，这如何转化为类似这样的场景呢：你在自己家的 Wi-Fi 下，另一个人在完全不同州的家里用着 Wi-Fi，
like how does that connection so starting with sort of the physical layer, what actually happens there? Yeah, so I guess the bare essentials for making a WebRTC connection start is how do you bootstrap that communication? Because me and you, if we're both inside our home networks, there's no way we can really talk to each other. I could give you my IP and you could give me my IP,
like how does that connection so starting with sort of the physical layer, what actually happens there? Yeah, so I guess the bare essentials for making a WebRTC connection start is how do you bootstrap that communication? Because me and you, if we're both inside our home networks, there's no way we can really talk to each other. I could give you my IP and you could give me my IP,|||这种连接是……那么，从物理层开始，那里到底发生了什么？是的，我想建立一个 WebRTC 连接的最基本要素是：你如何引导（bootstrap）这种通信？因为你和我，如果我们都在各自的家庭网络内部，我们实际上是无法直接对话的。我可以把我的 IP 给你，你也可以把你的 IP 给我，
but there's no way we can talk to each other. We both have, you know, private IPs. You know, if you've done any stuff, you'll see like the 192.168. So if you're starting at that level, how do we talk to each other? So usually how something like Google Hangouts works is first we bootstrap the call where I'll give you the minimum amount of information about me and I send it to Google. Google relays it to you, and then you send me the minimum information about you. So you send me, these are the video codecs I support, these are my IPs, and then we establish,
but there's no way we can talk to each other. We both have, you know, private IPs. You know, if you've done any stuff, you'll see like the 192.168. So if you're starting at that level, how do we talk to each other? So usually how something like Google Hangouts works is first we bootstrap the call where I'll give you the minimum amount of information about me and I send it to Google. Google relays it to you, and then you send me the minimum information about you. So you send me, these are the video codecs I support, these are my IPs, and then we establish,|||但我们根本无法交流。我们双方都有私有 IP。你知道的，如果你做过这方面的开发，你会看到像 192.168 这样的 IP。所以如果从这个层面开始，我们怎么交流？通常像 Google Hangouts 这样的服务是这样运作的：首先我们引导通话，我把关于我的最少量的的信息发给 Google。Google 将其转发给你，然后你把关于你的最少量的的信息发给我。所以你发给我：我支持这些视频编解码器，这些是我的 IP，然后我们建立……
that allows us to move on to the next step where we establish connectivity. And I think this is the really fun part, and the part that sort of was mind-bending for me is there is this idea that of NAT traversal. So if I send a UDP packet out on port 5000, and then you send a UDP packet back to me on the same port 5000 that I sent out on, the router will actually maintain this hole called a NAT hole punch and allow us to communicate. So all of a sudden, if we're in completely different networks,
that allows us to move on to the next step where we establish connectivity. And I think this is the really fun part, and the part that sort of was mind-bending for me is there is this idea that of NAT traversal. So if I send a UDP packet out on port 5000, and then you send a UDP packet back to me on the same port 5000 that I sent out on, the router will actually maintain this hole called a NAT hole punch and allow us to communicate. So all of a sudden, if we're in completely different networks,|||这使我们能够进入下一步，即建立连通性。我认为这部分非常有趣，也是让我觉得脑洞大开的部分，那就是 NAT 穿透（NAT traversal）的概念。因此，如果我通过 5000 端口发送一个 UDP 数据包，然后你向我发回一个 UDP 数据包，使用的正是我发送时用的那个 5000 端口，路由器实际上会维护一个称为“NAT 打洞（NAT hole punch）”的洞，从而允许我们进行通信。所以突然之间，如果我们处于完全不同的网络中，
because we've established who we are via that bootstrap message, we now can communicate directly. And there's a whole bunch of other protocols after that, but there's this initial bootstrapping that we've done where we've exchanged enough information to know what each other's public IPs are, and we've exchanged enough information to know what video codecs we support. We can now start hitting each other with video packets even though
because we've established who we are via that bootstrap message, we now can communicate directly. And there's a whole bunch of other protocols after that, but there's this initial bootstrapping that we've done where we've exchanged enough information to know what each other's public IPs are, and we've exchanged enough information to know what video codecs we support. We can now start hitting each other with video packets even though|||由于我们通过引导消息已经确定了各自是谁，我们现在就可以直接通信了。这之后还有一大堆其他的协议，但我们已经完成了最初的引导，交换了足够的信息以了解彼此的公网 IP 是什么，并且交换了足够的信息以了解我们支持哪些视频编解码器。我们现在可以开始向对方发送视频数据包了，尽管
there's no server in the middle it's just each of us sending to each other's public IPs and our router is passing it through to a computer inside the NAT without any overhead of server in the middle. Yeah totally so just to sort of unpack. So right now you send a letter to someone, you know, a physical snail mail letter. And on the front of that letter, that needs to have everything that the mail service needs, both your mail service
there's no server in the middle it's just each of us sending to each other's public IPs and our router is passing it through to a computer inside the NAT without any overhead of server in the middle. Yeah totally so just to sort of unpack. So right now you send a letter to someone, you know, a physical snail mail letter. And on the front of that letter, that needs to have everything that the mail service needs, both your mail service|||中间没有任何服务器，这只是我们各自向对方的公网 IP 发送数据，我们的路由器将其传递给 NAT 内部的计算机，而没有中间服务器的任何开销。是的，完全如此。所以我们来剖析一下。现在你给某人寄一封信，你知道的，是一封实体的邮政信件。在那封信的正面，需要写上邮政服务所需的一切信息，包括你的邮政服务
and the destination mail service needs to get that letter. So you write the person's house number, their address, you know, the country, if appropriate. You write all of that information and it's all right there on the front of the envelope. But the issue is, is, you know, on the on the Internet, there aren't that many IP addresses. And so there's many people who have like exactly the same address so what happens the way that works is is there's an envelope that says go to this neighborhood and then the person opens that envelope and there's
and the destination mail service needs to get that letter. So you write the person's house number, their address, you know, the country, if appropriate. You write all of that information and it's all right there on the front of the envelope. But the issue is, is, you know, on the on the Internet, there aren't that many IP addresses. And so there's many people who have like exactly the same address so what happens the way that works is is there's an envelope that says go to this neighborhood and then the person opens that envelope and there's|||和目的地的邮政服务将信件送达所需的信息。所以你要写上收件人的门牌号、地址、如果适用的话还有国家。你写下所有这些信息，它们都清清楚楚地印在信封正面。但问题是，在互联网上，IP 地址并没有那么多。所以有很多人拥有完全相同的地址。那么会发生什么呢？其运作方式是，有一个信封上写着“去这个街区”，然后这个人打开那个信封，里面还有
another envelope inside of that one that says okay this is the house i want and so even though there's so the way we would handle that in in you know in regular mail is you have the country the state and the zip code. But imagine just having those as sort of like these recursive envelopes. So you'd open the U.S. envelope, and then it says, okay, you have the Florida envelope. You open that, and then you say, okay, in Florida, I need this address, right? And that sort of de-dupes it.
another envelope inside of that one that says okay this is the house i want and so even though there's so the way we would handle that in in you know in regular mail is you have the country the state and the zip code. But imagine just having those as sort of like these recursive envelopes. So you'd open the U.S. envelope, and then it says, okay, you have the Florida envelope. You open that, and then you say, okay, in Florida, I need this address, right? And that sort of de-dupes it.|||另一个信封，上面写着“好的，这就是我想要的房子”。所以尽管……我们在常规邮件中处理这种情况的方法是，你有国家、州和邮政编码。但想象一下，如果把这些当作某种递归的信封。你会打开美国的信封，然后上面写着：“好的，你拿到了佛罗里达州的信封。”你打开它，然后说：“好的，在佛罗里达州，我需要这个地址，”对吧？这有点像是去重。
Yeah, and it's even the way I would think about it also so if you have let's say you have two neighborhoods and each of those neighborhoods have po boxes that's the only way you can communicate and those po boxes don't actually correlate to anyone inside the neighborhood but it's almost like if you if i send something outbound on a po box the mailman can assume that anything coming inbound to the same PO box is mine. So it's almost like this temporary association of a mailbox to a person. Yep. Yep.
Yeah, and it's even the way I would think about it also so if you have let's say you have two neighborhoods and each of those neighborhoods have po boxes that's the only way you can communicate and those po boxes don't actually correlate to anyone inside the neighborhood but it's almost like if you if i send something outbound on a po box the mailman can assume that anything coming inbound to the same PO box is mine. So it's almost like this temporary association of a mailbox to a person. Yep. Yep.|||是的，这也是我思考它的方式。假设你有两个街区，每个街区都有邮政信箱（PO Box），那是你们交流的唯一方式。这些邮政信箱实际上与街区内的任何人都没有直接关联，但这几乎就像是，如果我通过某个邮政信箱发送外发邮件，邮递员就可以假设任何发往同一个邮政信箱的入站邮件都是我的。所以这几乎就像是邮箱与人的一种临时关联。没错。没错。
Yeah. So, I mean, this is how otherwise nothing would work, right? So, you know, you go to Google and say, you know, Google, you know, send me the google.com front page. I need to make a search, right? And Google replies and says, okay, here it is. If that reply couldn't get to you, nothing on the internet would work.
Yeah. So, I mean, this is how otherwise nothing would work, right? So, you know, you go to Google and say, you know, Google, you know, send me the google.com front page. I need to make a search, right? And Google replies and says, okay, here it is. If that reply couldn't get to you, nothing on the internet would work.|||是的。所以我的意思是，否则这一切都无法运作，对吧？你知道的，你访问 Google 并说：“Google，把 google.com 的首页发给我，我要搜索。”然后 Google 回复说：“好的，给你。”如果那个回复无法送达你这里，互联网上的任何东西都无法工作。
So when you tell Google, hey, please send me the front page, all of the machines along the way keep track of your request. So all of them say, hey, this person, again know again in this state and this zip code in this neighborhood wanted google uh you know right now on this on this particular port and they sort of hold they reserve that that kind of area for you and then when google responds all of them kind of know where to route that and so as you said the trick is um there's there's this trick where you can actually use the same port to talk to two different machines. So you can talk to Google and say, hey, send me something back. And actually,
So when you tell Google, hey, please send me the front page, all of the machines along the way keep track of your request. So all of them say, hey, this person, again know again in this state and this zip code in this neighborhood wanted google uh you know right now on this on this particular port and they sort of hold they reserve that that kind of area for you and then when google responds all of them kind of know where to route that and so as you said the trick is um there's there's this trick where you can actually use the same port to talk to two different machines. So you can talk to Google and say, hey, send me something back. And actually,|||所以当你告诉 Google：“嘿，请把首页发给我”时，沿途的所有机器都会记录你的请求。所以它们都会说：“嘿，这个人，再次强调，在这个州、这个邮政编码、这个街区，现在通过这个特定的端口想要访问 Google……”它们会为你保留那块区域。然后当 Google 响应时，它们都知道该如何路由。正如你所说，这里的诀窍在于……有一个诀窍，你可以实际上使用同一个端口与两台不同的机器通信。所以你可以对 Google 说：“嘿，发点东西给我。”事实上，
if Yahoo kind of knows you're doing that, Yahoo could send something on the same port, and it will come to you as if it's coming from Google. I mean, you'll know it's from Yahoo because you can get the source IP address, but it will follow the same route as the Google packet and it can get to you. Now, if you don't have this trick where other people are replying, then people can't reach you
if Yahoo kind of knows you're doing that, Yahoo could send something on the same port, and it will come to you as if it's coming from Google. I mean, you'll know it's from Yahoo because you can get the source IP address, but it will follow the same route as the Google packet and it can get to you. Now, if you don't have this trick where other people are replying, then people can't reach you|||如果雅虎（Yahoo）知道你在这样做，雅虎也可以通过同一个端口发送东西，它发送给你的方式看起来就像是来自 Google 一样。我的意思是，你会知道它是来自雅虎的，因为你可以获取源 IP 地址，但它会遵循与 Google 数据包相同的路由并到达你这里。现在，如果你没有这种其他人可以回复的诀窍，那么别人就无法联系到你，
because as you said, people don't know at any given time who's in which house. And even if they did, the routers aren't going to let them figure that out. If I just right now send a packet to Sean's house, even if I know all the IP addresses on the way and say, hey, send this packet to Sean's printer, his router is not going to let that happen.
because as you said, people don't know at any given time who's in which house. And even if they did, the routers aren't going to let them figure that out. If I just right now send a packet to Sean's house, even if I know all the IP addresses on the way and say, hey, send this packet to Sean's printer, his router is not going to let that happen.|||因为正如你所说，在任何给定时间，人们都不知道谁在哪个房子里。即使他们知道，路由器也不会让他们弄清楚这一点。如果我现在给 Sean 的房子发送一个数据包，即使我知道沿途所有的 IP 地址并说：“嘿，把这个数据包发给 Sean 的打印机”，他的路由器也不会允许这种事发生。
But as soon as he starts communicating to me, whatever port that he talked to me on is now available for me and for other people to send data through. Yeah, and I think, and that also opens up other interesting possibilities because you have this one hole that anyone can send stuff into you
But as soon as he starts communicating to me, whatever port that he talked to me on is now available for me and for other people to send data through. Yeah, and I think, and that also opens up other interesting possibilities because you have this one hole that anyone can send stuff into you|||但只要他开始与我通信，他与我对话所使用的任何端口现在对我以及其他人来说都可以用来发送数据了。是的，我认为，这也开启了其他有趣的可能性，因为你有了这样一个洞，任何人都可以往里面发送东西，
and you start talking about things like torrents where you have this one hole and you'll be receiving data from thousands of peers through one hole that you've punched in your router. And the thing I also love is that all of these topics also apply to TCP. Even though we think of TCP as one stream of data, below the layers, it's a stateless connection where we're sending data over to a remote server,
and you start talking about things like torrents where you have this one hole and you'll be receiving data from thousands of peers through one hole that you've punched in your router. And the thing I also love is that all of these topics also apply to TCP. Even though we think of TCP as one stream of data, below the layers, it's a stateless connection where we're sending data over to a remote server,|||然后你开始谈论诸如 Torrent（种子下载）之类的事情，在这些事情中你有这样一个洞，你将通过在路由器上打的这个洞从成千上万的对端（peer）接收数据。我同样喜欢的一点是，所有这些主题也同样适用于 TCP。尽管我们认为 TCP 是一流的数据流，但在底层，它是一个无状态连接，我们将数据发送给远程服务器，
and that remote server is replying back to us. It's not a stream of data. It's the operating system and everything abstracts it away from us, but there's packet loss. You have to determine if the return data is coming from the proper IP and port so that it can simulate and feel a stream So there's all this magic that takes place behind the behind the scenes Yeah, and someone might say well, why would why would the routers trust that? Situation like if I send something to Google and I say hey, you know reply on port 3000 and then Yahoo replies
and that remote server is replying back to us. It's not a stream of data. It's the operating system and everything abstracts it away from us, but there's packet loss. You have to determine if the return data is coming from the proper IP and port so that it can simulate and feel a stream So there's all this magic that takes place behind the behind the scenes Yeah, and someone might say well, why would why would the routers trust that? Situation like if I send something to Google and I say hey, you know reply on port 3000 and then Yahoo replies|||然后远程服务器回复我们。它根本不是什么数据流。是操作系统和各种机制把它对我们抽象化了，但其中存在丢包。你必须确定返回的数据是否来自正确的 IP 和端口，以便它能够模拟并让人感觉是一个数据流。所以幕后发生了所有这些神奇的事情。是的，有人可能会说，为什么路由器会信任这种机制？比如如果我给 Google 发送东西并说：“嘿，在 3000 端口回复”，然后雅虎回复了，
Why don't I just block that and say hey you know i wanted google to reply and there are routers that do that in fact if you're on your cell connection that's how your cell tower works your cell tower will keep track of the destination and only allow people to come back packets to come back from that destination and so that's why for example you couldn't at least to my knowledge you can't run things like web rtc on a cell connection um if both people are on a cell connection because this trick doesn't work anymore yeah so one of the so what ends up having it and you'll what people end up using is something called a turn server and it's really all it is, is the idea that, okay, so my, let's say that your ISP doesn't
Why don't I just block that and say hey you know i wanted google to reply and there are routers that do that in fact if you're on your cell connection that's how your cell tower works your cell tower will keep track of the destination and only allow people to come back packets to come back from that destination and so that's why for example you couldn't at least to my knowledge you can't run things like web rtc on a cell connection um if both people are on a cell connection because this trick doesn't work anymore yeah so one of the so what ends up having it and you'll what people end up using is something called a turn server and it's really all it is, is the idea that, okay, so my, let's say that your ISP doesn't|||为什么我不直接阻止它并说：“嘿，我本来是想让 Google 回复的”？有些路由器确实会这样做。事实上，如果你使用的是蜂窝网络连接，你的手机基站就是这样工作的：你的基站会跟踪目标地址，并且只允许来自该目标地址的数据包返回。所以这就是为什么，据我所知，如果双方都在蜂窝网络上，你无法在蜂窝网络连接上运行 WebRTC 之类的东西，因为这个诀窍不再起作用了。所以最终导致的结果是，人们往往会使用一种叫做 TURN 服务器的东西，说白了，它的核心思想就是：假设你的 ISP（网络服务提供商）不
allow you to, doesn't support UDP traffic at all, or they don't support NAT hole punching. What you do is you establish a TCP connection up to a server in a data center that's public to both of you. So let's say a public IP, you connect up to it and say, I would like to speak to this person. And then that other person connects up to the turn server, and that turn server acts as a relay where it will allow that other person
allow you to, doesn't support UDP traffic at all, or they don't support NAT hole punching. What you do is you establish a TCP connection up to a server in a data center that's public to both of you. So let's say a public IP, you connect up to it and say, I would like to speak to this person. And then that other person connects up to the turn server, and that turn server acts as a relay where it will allow that other person|||允许你这样做，根本不支持 UDP 流量，或者不支持 NAT 打洞。你要做的是与双方都能访问的数据中心里的一个服务器建立一个 TCP 连接。比如说一个公网 IP，你连接到它并说：“我想和这个人说话。”然后另一个人连接到这个 TURN 服务器，这个 TURN 服务器充当一个中继，它将允许另一个人
to send communication to you through that turn server, and then that turn server will send it back to you. So that's the way that most people have to fall back to. And the statistics I've seen, Appear.in published this really great graph about all their calls, and I think 17% about all their calls. I think 17% of all their users were using turn servers.
to send communication to you through that turn server, and then that turn server will send it back to you. So that's the way that most people have to fall back to. And the statistics I've seen, Appear.in published this really great graph about all their calls, and I think 17% about all their calls. I think 17% of all their users were using turn servers.|||通过该 TURN 服务器向你发送通信数据，然后该 TURN 服务器会把它转发给你。这就是大多数人不得不采用的后备方案。根据我看到的统计数据，Appear.in 发布了一张关于他们所有通话的非常棒的图表，我认为大约有 17% 的通话。我认为他们有 17% 的用户在使用 TURN 服务器。
Yeah, so if you're working at, let's say, an IT firm, for example, or any of these sort of big areas that have very kind of locked down VPNs, and most office spaces will have what's called a symmetric NAT, which means symmetric because if you send a message to Google, you're only allowed to get back something from Google. That's the symmetry part of it. And yeah, in this case,
Yeah, so if you're working at, let's say, an IT firm, for example, or any of these sort of big areas that have very kind of locked down VPNs, and most office spaces will have what's called a symmetric NAT, which means symmetric because if you send a message to Google, you're only allowed to get back something from Google. That's the symmetry part of it. And yeah, in this case,|||是的，所以如果你在一家 IT 公司工作，或者在任何这种拥有非常严格的 VPN 的大公司工作，大多数办公场所都会有所谓的“对称型 NAT（symmetric NAT）”。之所以叫对称，是因为如果你给 Google 发送了一条消息，你只被允许接收来自 Google 的回复。这就是对称性的部分。是的，在这种情况下，
if one office is calling another office, then they'll have to use a turn server. Yeah, which I think is really unfortunate. And working on Pyon, a lot of companies I've run into is it's really just someone flipped a setting in a router or a firewall somewhere. How many people fall back to turn just because of accidents
if one office is calling another office, then they'll have to use a turn server. Yeah, which I think is really unfortunate. And working on Pyon, a lot of companies I've run into is it's really just someone flipped a setting in a router or a firewall somewhere. How many people fall back to turn just because of accidents|||如果一个办公室呼叫另一个办公室，那么他们就必须使用 TURN 服务器。是的，我觉得这真的很不幸。在参与 Pyon 项目的过程中，我遇到过很多公司，问题其实仅仅是某人在某个路由器或防火墙上改动了一个设置。有多少人仅仅是因为意外，
or using old networking hardware and stuff like that? I'm very excited for a future where which probably never will come where we all have you know publicly addressable ipv6 and we're all everything's be a peer-to-peer so someday yeah i mean i was thinking that as well i have a feeling that that you know even when we go ipv6 they'll definitely, it'll be again more like the post office where every packet will say exactly where it needs to be. But I have a feeling they'll still be
or using old networking hardware and stuff like that? I'm very excited for a future where which probably never will come where we all have you know publicly addressable ipv6 and we're all everything's be a peer-to-peer so someday yeah i mean i was thinking that as well i have a feeling that that you能 even when we go ipv6 they'll definitely, it'll be again more like the post office where every packet will say exactly where it needs to be. But I have a feeling they'll still be|||或者是使用了旧的网络硬件之类的原因，而不得不退回到使用 TURN？我非常期待这样一个未来（虽然可能永远不会到来）：我们都拥有可公开寻址的 IPv6，一切都是点对点的。所以总有一天……是的，其实我也有同感。我有一种感觉，即使我们过渡到了 IPv6，它们也绝对会更像是邮局，每个数据包都会明确指出它需要去哪里。但我有种预感，仍然会有
network managers that will enforce rules all the way down the chain. Yeah. And I think for me, the one thing I would love to solve is all the troubleshooting that goes into it. If you go to set up, you know, you want to build some WebRTC service right now.
network managers that will enforce rules all the way down the chain. Yeah. And I think for me, the one thing I would love to solve is all the troubleshooting that goes into it. If you go to set up, you know, you want to build some WebRTC service right now.|||网络管理员在整个链条的各个环节强制执行各种规则。是的。对我来说，我最想解决的一件事是其中涉及的所有故障排除。如果你去搭建……你知道的，如果你现在想构建某个 WebRTC 服务。
I feel people are really in the dark on this. There's not a lot of education around it. There's not a lot of tooling. And that's the next place I would love to see Pyon going is like, yes, we built a WebRTC implementation. And that's great. We're allowing people to do a lot of interesting things. But the amount of frustration and questions that still exist i'm not happy about i think that stuff can be a lot better there yep that totally makes sense actually one thing that that we didn't
I feel people are really in the dark on this. There's not a lot of education around it. There's not a lot of tooling. And that's the next place I would love to see Pyon going is like, yes, we built a WebRTC implementation. And that's great. We're allowing people to do a lot of interesting things. But the amount of frustration and questions that still exist i'm not happy about i think that stuff can be a lot better there yep that totally makes sense actually one thing that that we didn't|||我觉得人们在这方面真的是一无所知。相关的教育资源并不多，工具也不多。这也是我希望看到 Pyon 发展的下一个方向：是的，我们构建了一个 WebRTC 实现，这很棒，我们让人们能够做很多有趣的事情。但仍然存在的挫败感和各种问题让我觉得不够满意，我觉得那方面本可以做得更好。是的，这完全说得通。其实有一件事我们之前没有
mention that we should probably say pretty early is that web rdc isn't isn't just for websites um you know it's a it's a protocol for sending information. And definitely the easiest way to use it is in the browser. But the whole thesis of Pyon is that you can use this protocol in anything, in a desktop app, in a server thread, you know, whatever you want. Yeah, so some of the other ones I've seen, someone wrote something to share their terminal between two peers, and it's all just a command line application. So you start up a little process, and you say,
mention that we should probably say pretty early is that web rdc isn't isn't just for websites um you know it's a it's a protocol for sending information. And definitely the easiest way to use it is in the browser. But the whole thesis of Pyon is that you can use this protocol in anything, in a desktop app, in a server thread, you know, whatever you want. Yeah, so some of the other ones I've seen, someone wrote something to share their terminal between two peers, and it's all just a command line application. So you start up a little process, and you say,|||提到，而且我们可能应该在最开始就说清楚的，那就是 WebRTC 并不局限于网站。你知道的，它是一个用于发送信息的协议。毫无疑问，最简单的使用方式是在浏览器中。但 Pyon 的核心论点是，你可以在任何地方使用这个协议：在桌面应用中、在服务器线程中、或者任何你想要的地方。是的，我看到过其他的一些例子，有人编写了一个程序，可以在两个对端之间共享他们的终端，而这完全只是一个命令行应用程序。所以你启动一个小进程，然后说：
I think it's called WebTTY. So you start up WebTTY, and then you get this little bootstrap message, and you share it with the other computer. And then you both share your terminals back and forth with one acting as the host and one acting as the receiver. And I ended up using this in like a lockdown data center. So I'll have two hosts that are in the same NAT. And then it allows me to just share my terminal back and forth for debugging stuff, which is which has been super helpful. Wow, that's cool. Yeah, and so I really like that one.
I think it's called WebTTY. So you start up WebTTY, and then you get this little bootstrap message, and you share it with the other computer. And then you both share your terminals back and forth with one acting as the host and one acting as the receiver. And I ended up using this in like a lockdown data center. So I'll have two hosts that are in the same NAT. And then it allows me to just share my terminal back and forth for debugging stuff, which is which has been super helpful. Wow, that's cool. Yeah, and so I really like that one.|||我觉得它叫 WebTTY。所以你启动 WebTTY，然后你会得到这个小小的引导消息，把它分享给另一台计算机。然后你们互相共享终端，其中一台作为主机，另一台作为接收端。我最终在一个封闭的数据中心里用过这个。我有两台位于同一个 NAT 下的主机，它允许我来回共享终端来进行调试，这真的超级有用。哇，太酷了。是的，所以我真的很喜欢那个。
And then also, I just had someone come in and talk about doing a game engine using WebRTC for the multiplayer, because the nice thing, we can talk about this later, is with the data channels, you get to make the choice if the packets will be delivered in order and if the packets can be lossy. So you can say, like, only send the latest game state to the other person. So you constantly blast them with information. But then if something doesn't arrive on time, you just drop it. So the WebRTC, it's really amazing the amount of flexibility. And it's tough when you've been doing it for so long.
And then also, I just had someone come in and talk about doing a game engine using WebRTC for the multiplayer, because the nice thing, we can talk about this later, is with the data channels, you get to make the choice if the packets will be delivered in order and if the packets can be lossy. So you can say, like, only send the latest game state to the other person. So you constantly blast them with information. But then if something doesn't arrive on time, you just drop it. So the WebRTC, it's really amazing the amount of flexibility. And it's tough when you've been doing it for so long.|||还有，我刚刚遇到有人来谈论使用 WebRTC 为多人游戏制作游戏引擎，因为好消息是（我们等下可以讨论这个），通过数据通道（data channels），你可以选择数据包是否按顺序交付，以及数据包是否可以有损。所以你可以这样设定：只把最新的游戏状态发送给对方。因此你不断向他们轰炸信息，但如果某些东西没有按时到达，你直接丢弃它就行了。所以 WebRTC 的灵活性真的令人惊叹。当你从事这方面工作太久时，就会变得很难……
You forget the parts that are exciting or the parts that are new. You like talking about the stuff that's fun for you, but you forget about the whole breadth of everything. Yeah. I mean, I think that most people probably think that, for example, if you start a call, that it's going through a server. So if you use, I don't know, it's a good example, if you start a call, that it's going through a server. So if you use, I don't know, it's a good example, like Zoom or Skype or one of these things, that there's just a suite of servers and they're sort of bouncing all the information. And again, that can happen. That's the fallback.
You forget the parts that are exciting or the parts that are new. You like talking about the stuff that's fun for you, but you forget about the whole breadth of everything. Yeah. I mean, I think that most people probably think that, for example, if you start a call, that it's going through a server. So if you use, I don't know, it's a good example, if you start a call, that it's going through a server. So if you use, I don't know, it's a good example, like Zoom or Skype or one of these things, that there's just a suite of servers and they're sort of bouncing all the information. And again, that can happen. That's the fallback.|||你会忘记那些令人兴奋的部分或新鲜的部分。你喜欢谈论对你来说有趣的事情，却忽略了它的全貌。是的。我的意思是，我觉得大多数人大概会认为，举个例子，如果你发起一个通话，它是通过服务器进行的。所以如果你使用——我不知道，这是一个很好的例子——如果你发起一个通话，它是通过服务器进行的。所以如果你使用，比如说 Zoom、Skype 或类似的东西，那里就有一套服务器，它们负责转发所有的信息。再次说明，这种情况确实会发生，那是后备方案。
And so the turn servers enable that. But as you said, the vast majority of people are just talking straight computer to computer, which is really cool. Yeah. And I think it really comes down to two things. If you're running a business, the cost of having to do that, because if you're doing computer to computer, you have to process, you have to encrypt, you have to and then you have to do all the networking. So you're paying all the CPU costs and you're spending all these networking costs. I think it would be really hard for someone like Google to say, I'm going to provide Hangouts as a service
And so the turn servers enable that. But as you said, the vast majority of people are just talking straight computer to computer, which is really cool. Yeah, and it really comes down to two things. If you're running a business, the cost of having to do that, because if you're doing computer to computer, you have to process, you have to encrypt, you have to and then you have to do all the networking. So you're paying all the CPU costs and you're spending all these networking costs. I think it would be really hard for someone like Google to say, I'm going to provide Hangouts as a service|||因此 TURN 服务器支持了这一点。但正如你所说，绝大多数人其实都是直接进行点对点（电脑对电脑）通信的，这真的很酷.是的，这实际上归结为两件事。如果你在经营一家公司，这样做（通过服务器）的成本——因为如果你进行电脑到电脑的通信，你必须进行处理、必须加密、必须进行各种网络处理。所以你要承担所有的 CPU 成本，还要花费这些网络成本。我觉得像 Google 这样的人很难说：“我要将 Hangouts 作为一项服务提供，
and then pay who knows how much money to make all these calls work. So yeah, it's definitely an amazing piece of technology. I'm actually surprised, and maybe it's there, I just don't know about it yet, but it seems like for Netflix, if a new show comes out a lot of people try to get that show at the watch that show at the same time it seems like that's something they should they should be doing yeah the one that i loved is web torrent is is torrents via web rtc so that they you can um either you know
and then pay who knows how much money to make all these calls work. So yeah, it's definitely an amazing piece of technology. I'm actually surprised, and maybe it's there, I just don't know about it yet, but it seems like for Netflix, if a new show comes out a lot of people try to get that show at the watch that show at the same time it seems like that's something they should they should be doing yeah the one that i loved is web torrent is is torrents via web rtc so that they you can um either you know|||然后花不知道多少钱来让所有这些通话正常运行。”所以，这绝对是一项了不起的技术。其实我很惊讶——也许它已经存在了，只是我还没听说过——对于 Netflix 来说，如果有新剧上映，很多人试图同时观看那部剧，这似乎是他们应该去做的事情。是的，我最喜欢的一个项目是 WebTorrent，它是通过 WebRTC 实现的种子下载（Torrent），这样你就可以……要么，你知道的，
you can seed and you can download via your browser. And when you go to their website, I think it downloads Sintel. And it's amazing to watch how you download a real, you know, video that you can watch live via thousands of other peers. And it works just amazingly well. It really does feel like the future of content distribution to share it among a lot of peers. Yeah, that's fascinating. So for that to work, I guess the torrent servers, so there has to be other people with that website open right then and there, correct?
you can seed and you can download via your browser. And when you go to their website, I think it downloads Sintel. And it's amazing to watch how you download a real, you know, video that you can watch live via thousands of other peers. And it works just amazingly well. It really does feel like the future of content distribution to share it among a lot of peers. Yeah, that's fascinating. So for that to work, I guess the torrent servers, so there has to be other people with that website open right then and there, correct?|||你可以通过浏览器做种（seed）和下载。当你访问他们的网站时，我想它会下载 Sintel（开源动画短片）。看着你如何通过成千上万个其他对端下载一个真实可实时观看的视频，这种感觉太神奇了。它的运行效果好得惊人。在许多对端之间共享内容，真的让人感觉这就是内容分发的未来。是的，这太迷人了。所以为了让它正常工作，我猜那些 torrent 服务器——也就是当时当地必须有其他人打开那个网站，对吧？
Yeah, so they do have some headless boxes that are seeding. Like there's a WebRTC client that, no, it's not done and go, but they have one that's in JavaScript and it sits there and it acts as a seed box. But yeah, everyone who's connected, they connect over WebSocket to bootstrap and find the peers.
Yeah, so they do have some headless boxes that are seeding. Like there's a WebRTC client that, no, it's not done and go, but they have one that's in JavaScript and it sits there and it acts as a seed box. But yeah, everyone who's connected, they connect over WebSocket to bootstrap and find the peers.|||是的，他们确实有一些无头（headless）服务器在做种。比如有一个 WebRTC 客户端——不，它不是用 Go 写的，但他们有一个用 JavaScript 写的客户端，它就运行在那里，充当做种服务器。但是，是的，所有连接进来的用户，他们都是通过 WebSocket 进行引导并寻找对端的。
And then once you're bootstrapped, then all the actual data transfer occurs via WebRTC. Got it, I see. So there's just, it's one of these statistical things. It's such a popular site. There are always enough people there to make it work. I think there's a fair amount of clients that support the WebTorrent as well.
And then once you're bootstrapped, then all the actual data transfer occurs via WebRTC. Got it, I see. So there's just, it's one of these statistical things. It's such a popular site. There are always enough people there to make it work. I think there's a fair amount of clients that support the WebTorrent as well.|||一旦引导完成，所有实际的数据传输就会通过 WebRTC 进行。明白了，我懂了。所以这只是一种统计学上的必然。这是一个如此受欢迎的网站，总会有足够多的人在那里让它运作起来。我想也有相当数量的客户端支持 WebTorrent。
I forget, there's the Java-based one with the frog logo. Oh, um, oh, it's been so long since I used, um, but I know what you're talking about. Yeah. So, so they have WebTorrent support. So like the WebTorrent team has done an amazing job of like pushing forward this protocol and reaching out to people. Um, but yeah, there's a few, a few clients that don't, so they don't need to have their
I forget, there's the Java-based one with the frog logo. Oh, um, oh, it's been so long since I used, um, but I know what you're talking about. Yeah. So, so they have WebTorrent support. So like the WebTorrent team has done an amazing job of like pushing forward this protocol and reaching out to people. Um, but yeah, there's a few, a few clients that don't, so they don't need to have their|||我忘了，有一个基于 Java 的、带有青蛙标志的软件。哦，嗯……我已经好久没用过了，但我知道你在说什么。是的。所以，它们拥有 WebTorrent 支持。因此，WebTorrent 团队在推动这一协议和推广方面做出了惊人的工作。但是，是的，有一些客户端不支持，所以他们不需要让自己的
browser open that they're sharing the torrent as well. And so WebTorrent is, you said a javascript implementation and pion is a go implementation correct yeah yeah so there's so i know of there's a few clients but i know that there's like one of the struggles is using having the javascript implementation uses a full you have to run a full instance of chromium and they don't render it. They just, they run a headless Chromium to seed, but that's pretty expensive. So we've been trying to work on getting a Go implementation of it because it would be very, very lightweight compared to that. Yep. Yep. I think that that's the, that gets back to your point about how sort of confusing it is. I know I looked into using WebRTC a while back for a C++ application,
browser open that they're sharing the torrent as well. And so WebTorrent is, you said a javascript implementation and pion is a go implementation correct yeah yeah so there's so i know of there's a few clients but i know that there's like one of the struggles is using having the javascript implementation uses a full you have to run a full instance of chromium and they don't render it. They just, they run a headless Chromium to seed, but that's pretty expensive. So we've been trying to work on getting a Go implementation of it because it would be very, very lightweight compared to that. Yep. Yep. I think that that's the, that gets back to your point about how sort of confusing it is. I know I looked into using WebRTC a while back for a C++ application,|||浏览器开着来分享这个种子。所以你刚才说 WebTorrent 是一个 JavaScript 实现，而 Pyon 是一个 Go 实现，对吧？是的，是的。我了解有一些客户端，但我知道其中一个挣扎之处在于，使用 JavaScript 实现需要运行一个完整的 Chromium 实例，虽然它们不渲染页面。它们只是运行一个无头的 Chromium 来做种，但这成本挺高的。所以我们一直致力于开发它的 Go 语言实现，因为与那个相比，它会非常非常轻量。是的。是的。我觉得这又回到了你之前提到的关于它有多么让人困惑的观点。我知道我前段时间曾为某个 C++ 应用程序研究过如何使用 WebRTC，
and the instructions were pretty wild. It was build all of Chrome, link Chrome into your project, call these functions that are undocumented. It was just very odd, and I ended up having to bail on that project. Yeah, I think it's definitely been difficult. The tooling hasn't been out there. And the libraries themselves have been more targeted at large corporations or people that really know WebRTC already. Like if you go to WebRTC.org, I think there's an assumption that you already know how to use it. And we've seen like this new wave of WebRTC projects crop up. And so just in the last two years, we have a Python implementation called AIO RTC. We have a C++ implementation that was written from scratch that's super easy to use called RAW RTC.
and the instructions were pretty wild. It was build all of Chrome, link Chrome into your project, call these functions that are undocumented. It was just very odd, and I ended up having to bail on that project. Yeah, I think it's definitely been difficult. The tooling hasn't been out there. And the libraries themselves have been more targeted at large corporations or people that really know WebRTC already. Like if you go to WebRTC.org, I think there's an assumption that you already know how to use it. And we've seen like this new wave of WebRTC projects crop up. And so just in the last two years, we have a Python implementation called AIO RTC. We have a C++ implementation that was written from scratch that's super easy to use called RAW RTC.|||当时的说明书简直狂野：编译整个 Chrome，把 Chrome 链接到你的项目中，调用那些没有文档说明的函数。这实在是太奇怪了，我最终不得不放弃那个项目。是的，我承认这确实很难。相关的工具一直没跟上。而且库本身更多地是面向大公司或者那些对 WebRTC 已经非常了解的人。比如如果你访问 WebRTC.org，你会觉得那里默认你已经知道怎么使用了。但我们已经看到新一波的 WebRTC 项目如雨后春笋般涌现。所以在过去的两年里，我们有了一个名为 AIO RTC 的 Python 实现，我们有了一个从零开始编写的、超级易用的 C++ 实现叫做 RAW RTC，
And then we have Pyon. And then we have the GStreamer implementation. So there's a lot of new ones that are popping up recently. It's sort of seeing like a revitalization i mean it makes sense i think um you know one thing i did recently is is i signed up for the microsoft azure trial and actually in a future show we'll do a whole show on this the the public cloud services um but but it's actually it's it gets pretty expensive i mean even to just have one machine. Now, in my case, I was trying to use a pretty heavy machine to do some machine learning work.
And then we have Pyon. And then we have the GStreamer implementation. So there's a new ones that are popping up recently. It's sort of seeing like a revitalization i mean it makes sense i think um you know one thing i did recently is is i signed up for the microsoft azure trial and actually in a future show we'll do a whole show on this the the public cloud services um but but it's actually it's it gets pretty expensive i mean even to just have one machine. Now, in my case, I was trying to use a pretty heavy machine to do some machine learning work.|||然后我们有了 Pyon，然后我们有了 GStreamer 实现。所以最近涌现出了很多新项目。它看起来正在经历某种复兴。这讲得通，我想……你知道的，我最近做的一件事是注册了微软 Azure 的试用版，其实在以后的节目中我们会专门做一整期来讨论公共云服务。但实际上，它变得相当昂贵，我是说仅仅拥有一台机器。就我而言，我当时试图用一台配置相当高的机器来做一些机器学习的工作。
But I think it was, if I had that machine running all day for a month, it was $1,000, which is nuts. I think it came down to, I think, $1 an hour or maybe $0.50 an hour. I don't quite remember how it breaks down. Someone will fact check me on that, but, um, but yeah, it's, it's not cheap. Right. And so, and so, and the, and the costs right now are, they're not with the public cloud, they're not capital costs. They're sort of operating costs. So, so you're going to, you're going to have to, your small company is going to have to reach into its pocketbook and, and come up with a thousand dollars every month um and so i think that that could be part of the reason why um why why this
But I think it was, if I had that machine running all day for a month, it was $1,000, which is nuts. I think it came down to, I think, $1 an hour or maybe $0.50 an hour. I don't quite remember how it breaks down. Someone will fact check me on that, but, um, but yeah, it's, it's not cheap. Right. And so, and so, and the, and the costs right now are, they're not with the public cloud, they're not capital costs. They're sort of operating costs. So, so you're going to, you're going to have to, your small company is going to have to reach into its pocketbook and, and come up with a thousand dollars every month um and so i think that that could be part of the reason why um why this|||但我估计，如果让那台机器一个月全天候运行，费用将达到 1000 美元，这太疯狂了。我记得算下来大概是每小时 1 美元，或者可能是每小时 0.5 美元。我记不太清具体怎么算的了，回头会有人核实我的说法，但……总之，这绝对不便宜。没错。所以，现在的这些成本并不是公共cloud的资本支出（固定资产投资），它们某种程度上是运营成本。所以，你的小公司将不得不掏出钱包，每个月拿出 1000 美元。所以我觉得这可能是为什么……为什么这项技术如此受欢迎的原因之一。
technology is so popular i think part of it too is um just a real uh you know urge for for for people and for companies to decentralize a bit um that's really exciting too yeah and the other going back to the running servers and i think a big one i've seen is also the operational costs that you you know you can spin up a thousand servers and you can manage them wonderfully via kubernetes or you can manage them wonderfully and have each be an own vm that's managed via something um but there's just there's always going to be issues you always have you know someone will say oh this random service is acting weird can you kick it reboot it and you
technology is so popular i think part of it too is um just a real uh you know urge for for for people and for companies to decentralize a bit um that's really exciting too yeah and the other going back to the running servers and i think a big one i've seen is also the operational costs that you you know you can spin up a thousand servers and you can manage them wonderfully via kubernetes or you can manage them wonderfully and have each be an own vm that's managed via something um but there's just there's always going to be issues you always have you know someone will say oh this random service is acting weird can you kick it reboot it and you|||我也觉得部分原因在于，人们和公司确实有一种强烈的去中心化的冲动，这也非常令人兴奋。是的，回到运行服务器的话题，我看到的另一个重大问题也是运营成本。你知道的，你可以启动一千台服务器，然后通过 Kubernetes 把它们管理得井井有条，或者你可以把它们管理得很好，让每个服务器都是一个由某种工具管理的独立虚拟机。但问题总是会层出不穷，总会有人跑过来说：“哦，这个随機服务表现得有点怪，你能把它踢掉重启一下吗？”你
have to design all these things like it's so nice when you're just running one server to handle that that signaling bootstrapping and then everything just works yeah that totally makes sense yeah i think i mean although to be fair you're going to have now the end user saying hey i can't i can't reach this person but is there any case where turn will fail i guess for turn to fail you have to like the whole internet i mean i mean just making a connection would have to not work right so it seems pretty rare so you can so turn has to run soN can run over TLS, TCP, and you can run it on 443. So if the only case I can think of is if who you're connecting via doesn't allow TLS traffic, they only allow plain text HTTP, and then they do actual deep packet inspection.
have to design all these things like it's so nice when you're just running one server to handle that that signaling bootstrapping and then everything just works yeah that totally makes sense yeah i think i mean although to be fair you're going to have now the end user saying hey i can't i can't reach this person but is there any case where turn will fail i guess for turn to fail you have to like the whole internet i mean i mean just making a connection would have to not work right so it seems pretty rare so you can so turn has to run soN can run over TLS, TCP, and you can run it on 443. So if the only case I can think of is if who you're connecting via doesn't allow TLS traffic, they only allow plain text HTTP, and then they do actual deep packet inspection.|||不得不去设计所有这些东西。相比之下，当你只运行一台服务器来处理信令引导，然后一切都能顺利运转时，那种感觉真是太美妙了。是的，这完全说得通。是的，我想……不过平心而论，你现在会遇到终端用户说：“嘿，我联系不上这个人。”但是，有没有什么情况下 TURN 会失效呢？我想如果要让 TURN 失效，那得是整个互联网……我是说，仅仅是建立连接这件事就得完全行不通才行，所以这似乎相当罕见。所以你可以……TURN 必须运行，嗯，它可以运行在 TLS、TCP 之上，并且你可以把它运行在 443 端口上。所以能让我想到的唯一失效情况是，你通过连接的那个网络不允许 TLS 流量，他们只允许明文 HTTP，而且他们还做了实际的深度数据包检测（DPI）。
So they look at the contents of the packets and say, like, is this actual HTTP or not? Then it could fail. So I could see there are some cases where like super restrictive like healthcare or government where webrtc they're they're inspecting every packet and it absolutely won't work um in the real world i i think it's a safe bet yeah that makes sense so um yeah let's let's try to maybe give people a recap of this because it's definitely a lot to graph. So correct me if I'm wrong here, but I think so the first step is, again, going to that envelope metaphor is you need to know the outermost envelope because you need to send that to somebody so that they can get a way to reach you. get a way to reach you and so that's that's what stun is doing right yes and so and so the the stun servers and because that's a pretty cheap process there's a bunch of these public stun servers i know google maintains one um i think mozilla maintains one and so there's it's just a set of servers out on the internet that you can reach from almost any machine,
So they look at the contents of the packets and say, like, is this actual HTTP or not? Then it could fail. So I could see there are some cases where like super restrictive like healthcare or government where webrtc they're they're inspecting every packet and it absolutely won't work um in the real world i i think it's a safe bet yeah that makes sense so um yeah let's let's try to maybe give people a recap of this because it's definitely a lot to graph. So correct me if I'm wrong here, but I think so the first step is, again, going to that envelope metaphor is you need to know the outermost envelope because you need to send that to somebody so that they can get a way to reach you. get a way to reach you and so that's that's what stun is doing right yes and so and so the the stun servers and because that's a pretty cheap process there's a bunch of these public stun servers i know google maintains one um i think mozilla maintains one and so there's it's just a set of servers out on the internet that you can reach from almost any machine,|||也就是说，他们会查看数据包的内容并判断：“这真的是 HTTP 吗？”如果是的话，它可能会失败。所以我能看到在某些超级严格的场景下，比如医疗保健或政府机构，他们会检查每一个数据包，WebRTC 绝对无法工作。但在现实世界中，我觉得这是一个稳妥的赌注。是的，这说得通。所以，嗯，让我们试着为听众做个总结，因为这要吸收的东西实在太多了。如果我理解错了请纠正我，但我认为第一步，再次借用那个信封的比喻，你需要知道最外层的信封，因为你需要把它寄给某人，这样他们才能找到联系你的方法。这就是 STUN（Session Traversal Utilities for NAT）正在做的事情，对吧？是的。所以，STUN 服务器——因为这是一个相当廉价的过程，网上有很多这样的公共 STUN 服务器，我知道 Google 维护了一个，Mozilla 好像也维护了一个。所以它们只是一组部署在互联网上的服务器，你可以从几乎任何机器上访问它们，
and they will just tell you what your public IP address is. Yeah, and then they tell you what your public IP address is, and then they establish that hole in your NAT. So they can say, this is your public IP address, and this is the port, and if anyone sends into this IP port combination, it'll end up on your local machine. So, yeah, question about that.
and they will just tell you what your public IP address is. Yeah, and then they tell you what your public IP address is, and then they establish that hole in your NAT. So they can say, this is your public IP address, and this is the port, and if anyone sends into this IP port combination, it'll end up on your local machine. So, yeah, question about that.|||它们会直接告诉你你的公网 IP 地址是什么。是的，然后它们告诉你你的公网 IP 地址是什么，接着它们在你的 NAT 中建立那个洞。所以它们可以指出：“这是你的公网 IP 地址，这是端口，如果任何人向这个 IP 和端口的组合发送数据，它最终都会到达你的本地机器。”所以，关于这一点我有个问题。
And I just thought of this now, so this could make no sense, but is there a way to detect if you have a symmetric NAT by on the same source port, you reach two stun servers and they tell you two different answers? Is that some way to tell in advance that this is not going to work out?
And I just thought of this now, so this could make no sense, but is there a way to detect if you have a symmetric NAT by on the same source port, you reach two stun servers and they tell you two different answers? Is that some way to tell in advance that this is not going to work out?|||我是刚刚才想到这个的，所以这可能完全没有道理：有没有这样一种方法来检测你是否处于对称型 NAT 后面——通过使用相同的源端口访问两个 STUN 服务器，而它们给出了两个不同的答案？这算不算是预先判断此路不通的一种方法？
So someone wrote a command line application that's able to detect your NAT type. And I'm trying to think of how it works. I do believe it's possible, but I forget off the top of my head. I'm sorry. Yeah, so no, it's fine. But I think that would work.
So someone wrote a command line application that's able to detect your NAT type. And I'm trying to think of how it works. I do believe it's possible, but I forget off the top of my head. I'm sorry. Yeah, so no, it's fine. But I think that would work.|||有人编写过一个能够检测你的 NAT 类型的命令行应用程序。我正在回想它是怎么运作的。我确实相信这是可能的，但我一时想不起来了，抱歉。好的，没关系。但我认为那确实行得通。
And yeah, so again, someone on the show, I'm sure will write in and say why this doesn't work. But yeah, so you say, okay, on port 3000, I want to reach Google's stun server. And I also want to reach your Yahoo stun server. And Google's one comes back and says, Oh, I opened this port for you, port 1000. And then the Yahoo one comes back and says, Oh, I opened, you know, your router opened port 2000. That's sort of a sign that like, okay, your router is not letting Yahoo use the Google one. Yeah, and it's a sign that like every outbound packet is going to have a different source. So it's how the other side, since the other side depends on the source port being the same every time it was the other nat is just going to throw away each packet right yep that's right and so how does this relate to upnp and the nat pnp and those things yeah yeah so the so i saw someone bring this up and i'm actually not
And yeah, so again, someone on the show, I'm sure will write in and say why this doesn't work. But yeah, so you say, okay, on port 3000, I want to reach Google's stun server. And I also want to reach your Yahoo stun server. And Google's one comes back and says, Oh, I opened this port for you, port 1000. And then the Yahoo one comes back and says, Oh, I opened, you know, your router opened port 2000. That's sort of a sign that like, okay, your router is not letting Yahoo use the Google one. Yeah, and it's a sign that like every outbound packet is going to have a different source. So it's how the other side, since the other side depends on the source port being the same every time it was the other nat is just going to throw away each packet right yep that's right and so how does this relate to upnp and the nat pnp and those things yeah yeah so the so i saw someone bring this up and i'm actually not|||是的，所以再次说明，节目的一位听众肯定会写信来指出为什么这行不通。但总之，你是说：“好吧，在 3000 端口，我想连接 Google 的 STUN 服务器。我还想连接雅虎的 STUN 服务器。”Google 的服务器返回说：“哦，我为你打开了这个端口，端口 1000。”然后雅虎的服务器返回说：“哦，我打开了……你知道的，你的路由器打开了端口 2000。”这基本上是一个信号，表明：“好吧，你的路由器不让雅虎使用 Google 开的那个洞。”是的，这表明每个出站数据包都会有不同的源端口。所以对方由于依赖每次都相同的源端口，另一个 NAT 就会直接丢弃每一个数据包，对吧？是的，完全正确。那么这与 UPnP、NAT-PMP 以及这些东西有什么关系呢？是的，我看到有人提起这个，我其实并不
familiar with i've never written a upnp application but the way it was explained to me is that most routers just ended up disabling it. It had a bunch of promise in the early 2000s, but it just had issues where people assumed if I have UPnP enabled, that malware is going to turn it on. And just to explain what UPnP is, so what we've been talking about is stun servers, where you reach out, you talk to someone,
familiar with i've never written a upnp application but the way it was explained to me is that most routers just ended up disabling it. It had a bunch of promise in the early 2000s, but it just had issues where people assumed if I have UPnP enabled, that malware is going to turn it on. And just to explain what UPnP is, so what we've been talking about is stun servers, where you reach out, you talk to someone,|||熟悉它，我从来没有编写过 UPnP 应用程序。但向我解释的人是这样说的：大多数路由器最终都选择禁用了它。它在 2000 年代初期曾充满希望，但它存在一些问题，人们认为如果开启了 UPnP，恶意软件就会利用它。顺便解释一下什么是 UPnP：我们刚才一直在讨论 STUN 服务器，你向外发起连接，与某人对话，
and then it opens up a hole in your NAT temporarily where anyone can contact an inner computer via an outer IP address. What UPnP was is that an inner computer can connect to the router and say, okay, I want port 6000, and then your computer can open up holes in your NAT however it wants with whatever rules it wants and which is cool and all like that's the best way to establish peer-to-peer connectivity
and then it opens up a hole in your NAT temporarily where anyone can contact an inner computer via an outer IP address. What UPnP was is that an inner computer can connect to the router and say, okay, I want port 6000, and then your computer can open up holes in your NAT however it wants with whatever rules it wants and which is cool and all like that's the best way to establish peer-to-peer connectivity|||然后它会在你的 NAT 中临时打开一个洞，任何人都可以通过外网 IP 地址联系到内网计算机。而 UPnP 的机制是，内网计算机可以连接到路由器并说：“好的，我想要 6000 端口”，然后你的计算机就可以随心所欲地在 NAT 中打开任意规则的洞了。这确实很酷，而且这也是建立点对点连接的最佳方式。
because you don't have to depend on a stun server you can just communicate back and forth but people ended up disabling it and those and I saw people talk a little bit about it but why it is why isn't it in WebRc and no one has given enough attention to even talk about it in the iatf or anything like that yep yeah that makes sense yeah i think i mean there's a lot of issues so yeah you you hit the nail on the head it's basically a way to instead of instead of doing this process and and and getting this route backwards you just make the route forwards you know you just you just say okay anyone who wants to talk to my router on port 8000 is really talking to me and you just do that up front and then and then anytime you send anything it comes back on that
因为你不需要依赖 stun 服务器，你可以直接进行点对点通信，但人们最终还是禁用了它，我看到人们对此进行了一些讨论，但为什么 WebRTC 中没有这个，而且没有人在 IETF 或类似机构中给予足够的关注来谈论它，是的，这说得通，是的，我认为我的意思是这有很多问题，所以你一针见血，它基本上是一种方法，不用经历这个过程并反向获取这条路由，而是直接正向获取路由，你知道的，你只是说，好吧，任何想要连接到我路由器 80 号端口的人实际上都在和我说话，你提前做好这一点，然后随时发送任何东西它都会从那个端口返回
um but yeah i mean the if you have two rout, right away you're dead in the water, right? So, I mean, if you're part of an apartment complex and you have your Wi-Fi and it's connected to their Wi-Fi, then you can't actually change their UPnP settings. So, yeah, it's all the people who would have that kind of control would already be supported by stun yeah and I think the nice thing about stun is it's such a standard it's such a minimal standard and then it's not something that you have to deal with each router manufacturer like if WebRTC if we had to have you know
嗯，但是如果路由断开，你马上就死路一条了，对吧？所以，如果你在一个公寓大楼里，你有你的 Wi-Fi，它连接到他们的 Wi-Fi，那么你实际上无法更改他们的 UPnP 设置。所以，是的，所有拥有这种控制权的人都已经得到了 stun 的支持，我认为 stun 的好处在于它是一个如此标准、如此最简的标准，而且你不需要和每个路由器制造商打交道，就像 WebRTC 如果我们必须拥有
UPnP library and have all these if def to work with each hardware manufacturer that does something wrong I could see that sort of blowing out of proportion eventually. Yep, yep, totally makes sense. So we talked about how it hinges on this sort of trick with people replying back. And so when you talk about it, it sounds definitely cool,
UPnP 库，并有所有这些条件编译来处理做错事的硬件制造商，我可以看到这种情况最终会失控。是的，完全说得通。所以我们讨论了它是如何取决于这种带有回复的人的技巧的。所以当你谈论它时，听起来确实很酷，
like hacking and using the system, not the way it's designed. Is this like a wild west? Is there any security here? Can people trust WebRTC to do anything secure? Yes. So WebRTC itself, once you've established the connectivity, the first thing it does is it starts a TLS handshake. Basically, there's TLS via UDP,
就像黑客攻击和使用系统一样，而不是按照它的设计方式。这就像是狂野西部吗？这里有安全性可言吗？人们可以信任 WebRTC 来做任何安全的事情吗？是的。所以 WebRTC 本身，一旦你建立了连接，它做的第一件事就是启动 TLS 握手。基本上，通过 UDP 有 TLS，
which is called DTLS or Datagram. So you might have to explain TLS for folks. Yeah. So the TLS is, it works off this concept of Diffie-Hellman. And the idea is that if I can choose a private number and you can choose a private number, we are able to exchange our public numbers and via a rule of powers, I believe,
这被称为 DTLS 或数据报。所以你可能需要为听众解释一下 TLS。是的。所以 TLS 的工作原理是基于迪菲-赫尔曼这个概念。这个想法是，如果我能选择一个私有数字，你也能选择一个私有数字，我们就能够交换我们的公共数字，并且通过幂运算规则，我相信，
that we can figure out each other's private numbers without someone who's snooping in the middle being able to figure out. And TLS, if you've ever seen the green lock up in the corner of your browser or you know that it's HTTPS is basically HTTPS just means that you're running over over TLS. And so WebRTC, when it first when it's able to establish connectivity, it establishes that green lock. And this is all just built in the protocol. So you can never talk to another WebRTC peer unless the first thing they do is speak TLS as well. Yeah, that totally makes sense. And so, yeah, if somebody else tries to, even though they can reach your computer and they could send you as many packets as they want, you know it's coming from them because they
我们可以算出彼此的私有数字，而中间的窃听者却无法算出。TLS，如果你在浏览器角落看到过绿色小锁，或者你知道它是 HTTPS，HTTPS 基本上只意味着你正在通过 TLS 运行。因此，WebRTC 当它首次能够建立连接时，它会建立那个绿色小锁。而这一切都内置在协议中。所以你永远不可能与另一个 WebRTC 对端进行对话，除非他们做的第一件事也是使用 TLS。是的，这完全说得通。所以，是的，如果其他人试图，即使他们可以连接到你的计算机，并且可以向你发送任意数量的数据包，你知道它是来自他们，因为他们
won't be able to sign their packets correctly. Yeah. would be able to sign their packets correctly yeah and so the um so once you what you do is you um once you establish this tls connection you have enough crypto state and you encrypt your packets and you add an off tag to the end and so if i receive information from someone that's encrypted i can if what i do is first I check the tail of the packet and I'll have this off tag and that off tag will tell me is this actually valid and then if that off tag is valid then actually decrypt it and that's like the two main concepts there is is something authenticated and then it's something
无法正确对数据包进行签名。是的，能够正确对数据包进行签名，是的，所以一旦你建立了这个 TLS 连接，你就有了足够的加密状态，你加密你的数据包并在末尾添加一个 auth 标签，所以如果我从某人那里收到加密的信息，如果我的做法是首先检查数据包的尾部，我会看到这个 auth 标签，这个 auth 标签会告诉我这是否真的有效，然后如果这个 auth 标签有效，那么实际解密它，这就是两个主要概念，有些东西是经过身份验证的，然后有些东西是
actually encrypted. So yeah so everything via WebRTC it's it's always encrypted by default and it's sort of and that's and that's a nice thing via WebRTC it's always encrypted by default and it's sort of and that's a nice thing about WebRTC if you're coming from VoIP or coming from other industries is basically we just WebRTC just took a bunch of existing protocols the one that we're talking about getting across networks is called
实际加密的。所以，是的，通过 WebRTC 的所有内容默认都是加密的，而且这也是 WebRTC 的一个优点，如果你来自 VoIP 或其他行业，基本上我们只是 WebRTC 采用了一堆现有的协议，我们正在谈论的穿透网络的协议叫做
ICE the one we're talking about is DTLS and SRTP and then later we'll probably talk about like the data channels which is SCTP, is they took all of these things that already worked, that people were already building products out of, and just wrapped it up into one package and made it easy to use. So actually one thing, so I guess a precursor to the security part is the identity part, right? So if everyone's talking to each other, how does anybody know who anyone else
ICE，我们谈论的是 DTLS 和 SRTP，然后稍后我们可能会谈论类似数据通道的内容，即 SCTP，他们把所有这些已经有效、人们已经用它们构建产品的东西打包成一个包，并使其易于使用。所以实际上有一件事，我想安全部分的一个前提是身份部分，对吧？所以如果每个人都在互相交谈，怎么会有人知道其他人是谁
is? So when you have that initial bootstrap message, you share a fingerprint of the certificate that you're going to share via DTLS. So if you look at that initial bootstrap message, you'll see SHA-256, then you'll see this long value. And what that does is after the DTLS handshake is over, each side exports the message that happened. They export the certificate that was shared and they confirm, okay, the certificate that we agreed upon, was it actually the one that they shared via that bootstrap message? So if you, let's say that someone tried to man in the middle you
呢？所以当你拥有初始的引导消息时，你会分享将通过 DTLS 分享的证书的指纹。所以如果你看一下那个初始的引导消息，你会看到 SHA-256，然后你会看到这个很长的值。它的作用是，在 DTLS 握手结束后，双方都会导出发生的消息。他们导出共享的证书并确认，好吧，我们商定的证书真的是他们通过那个引导消息共享的证书吗？所以如果你，比方说有人试图对你进行中间人攻击，
and they connected with a different WebRTC instance, they couldn't generate that same fingerprint. And so after you connected and after you did the DTLS, you both would export your fingerprints and it would fail. And it would say, like, I've been attacked. Hang up. Got it. So the idea is it starts, as you said, with that number, and each person picks their own number, and the the the
并且他们使用不同的 WebRTC 实例进行连接，他们无法生成相同的指纹。因此，在你连接之后，在你进行 DTLS 之后，你们两个都会导出你们的指纹，并且它会失败。它会显示，比如，我受到了攻击。挂断。明白了。所以这个想法是它开始了，正如你所说，从那个数字开始，每个人选择他们自己的数字，而
the range of numbers is very very large so the odds that two people pick the same number impossibly low um and then that number kind of becomes your identity and then once the connection is established then you could say um you could say hey i'm john smith right and then you run into all the identity issues there, right? I mean, we could have a perfectly valid connection where it's definitely this computer in this location, this computer in that location, and the person says, you know, I'm the president of Japan,
数字的范围非常非常大，所以两个人选择同一个数字的概率低得不可思议，然后这个数字有点变成了你的身份，一旦连接建立，你就可以说，你可以说，嘿，我是约翰·史密斯，然后你就会遇到那里的所有身份问题，对吧？我的意思是，我们可以有一个完全有效的连接，它绝对是这个位置的这台计算机，那个位置的那台计算机，然后这个人说，你知道，我是日本首相，
and if you believe them, well, that's on you, right? Yeah. And I think when I was, so when I wrote the Go implementation of Dls something that came super handy and i'll share the link so we can have it later is um someone wrote something called the illustrated tls connection which was super helpful because you have all you just have all of these all this cryptographic information being exchanged and i didn't really know what was going on and um it's a super helpful thing where you can look at
如果你相信他们，嗯，那是你的事，对吧？是的。我认为当我编写 Dtls 的 Go 实现时，有一件事非常方便，我会分享链接以便我们稍后可以查看，有人写了名为“图解 TLS 连接”的东西，这超级有帮助，因为你拥有所有这些加密信息正在交换，我真的不知道发生了什么，它超级有用，你可以查看
each packet and see it actually shares a bunch of different information. You generate local random data and then they generate random data. You exchange the amount of ciphers that you support. There's a bunch of different cipher types and stuff like that. There's a lot of things. It's a super interesting thing that I think you could dive into for hours if you if you like talking about that stuff. But we should we should share that like this is something that taught me a lot.
每个包并看到它实际上共享了一堆不同的信息。你生成本地随机数据，然后他们生成随机数据。你交换你支持的密码套件数量。有很多不同的密码类型之类的东西。有很多东西。这是一个非常有趣的事情，如果你喜欢谈论这些东西，我认为你可以深入研究几个小时。但我们应该分享这个，这教会了我很多东西。
And then I bought a book. It was like some like intro level textbook on cryptography so I could learn this stuff. I wonder if there's some way. Is there some way to pick to make part of that number uh you know specific like in other words i wonder if there's some way to embed your let's say twitter handle into that into the secret key in some way where people uh could could attach it to some other identity um i feel like that would probably break the encryption but no that's a super yeah so once you figure out the other party's number and i but i think that's pretty much what a certificate is already is instead of instead of it being you know your
然后我买了一本书。这是一本关于密码学的入门级教科书，这样我就可以学习这些东西了。我想知道是否有某种方法。有没有什么方法可以选择让该数字的一部分，你知道，具有特定性，换句话说，我想知道是否有某种方法可以将你的，比方说推特用户名嵌入到密钥中的某种方式，人们可以将它附加到其他一些身份，我觉得这可能会破坏加密，不，这超级，是的，一旦你弄清楚了另一方的数字，但我认为这几乎已经是一个证书了，而不是你的
twitter handle it's this long random thing that's generated and i guess but no i see no reason why that couldn't work at all because really the number you know the number could just be uh ascii of your Twitter handle. And I think something like that could easily work. But again, I'm not a cryptographer. I'm sure that if someone's listening to this and is going to wince in pain at my misunderstanding.
推特用户名，它是生成的一大串随机东西，我想，但我不认为这完全行不通，因为实际上这个数字，你知道，这个数字可以只是你的推特用户名的 ASCII 码。我认为类似的事情可以很容易地起作用。但再说一次，我不是密码学家。我确信如果有人听到这个并且会对我的误解感到痛苦。
Same here. But yeah, I guess the issue is, at the end of the day, is identity, right? It doesn't matter how secure the connection is. At some point, someone's going to say they have this identity, again, they're the president of Japan, and at some point you have to trust that that is true.
我也是。但是，是的，我想问题归根结底是身份，对吧？无论连接有多安全都无所谓。在某个时候，有人会说他们拥有这个身份，再次强调，他们是日本首相，而在某个时候你必须相信这是真的。
The thing that this gives you is continuity. So if you know someone's the president of Japan and they reach out to you over WebRTC a week later with the same signature, then you know you're still talking to the same person. Yeah, and then also it's this ability to
这赋予你的是连续性。所以如果你知道某人是日本首相，而他们在几周后通过 WebRTC 使用相同的签名联系你，那么你就知道你仍在与同一个人交谈。是的，然后这也是一种能力，
yeah, no, I think it just comes down to identity and it comes down to how do you establish identity without having some kind of central authority? Because with WebRTC, you don't have the ability to go and, because when you do a website, you know, you buy your certificate from VeriSign. And then so someone downloads the certificate and say, okay, I got the certificate
是的，不，我认为这归结为身份，归结为在没有某种中央权威的情况下如何建立身份？因为对于 WebRTC，你没有能力去，因为当你制作一个网站时，你知道，你从 VeriSign 购买你的证书。然后有人下载证书并说，好吧，我从 google.com 获得了证书。让我看看是谁把它卖给 google.com 的。我可以用它们吗 使用 webrtc 所有这些证书都是由浏览器生成的，所以通过那个引导消息它说，好吧，我将带着这个指纹与另一个浏览器交谈，但在一天结束时，没有下一个可以去找的人，你必须说，好吧，我收到了他们声称发送给我的证书，就是这样。所以，是的，如果某人有一个，比方说他们有一台台式机和一部手机，他们如何在设备之间拥有一个连贯的身份？我不认为他们有，我不认为你可以。就像，我认为每次你启动一个新的 WebRTC 连接时，它都可能是，另一方没有办法判断，这是同一个人还是其他人？明白了。这说得通。所以如果你想要那样做，我的意思是，如果你想构建一个像这样的产品，比方说你想在我们的，在网络 rtc 上构建一个论坛，你可能需要某种中央服务器来管理身份，否则每个人，每一个，每一个网页浏览器框架都会是一个不同的人。哦，所以你可以做的一件事是 WebRTC 默认会为每个连接生成一个新的证书，你可以做的是
from google.com. Let me see who sold it to google.com. Can I them with webrtc all of these certificates are generated by the browser so all it so via that bootstrapping message it says okay i'm going to be talking to this other browser with this fingerprint but at the end of the day there's no next person to go to like you have to say okay i got the certificate they claimed they were sending me that's it so yeah if somebody has a you know let's say that they have a desktop and they have a phone, how did they have a, you know, a coherent identity across devices? I don't think they, I don't think you can. Like, I think every time you start up a new WebRTC connection, it could be, there's no
来自 google.com。让我看看是谁把它卖给 google.com 的。我可以用 WebRTC 连接他们吗？所有这些证书都是由浏览器生成的，因此这一切都通过引导消息进行，它说好的，我将使用这个指纹与另一个浏览器通信，但归根结底，没有下一个可信任的人可以去验证，你只能说，好的，我收到了他们声称发给我的证书，就是这样。所以，是的，如果某人拥有一台台式机和一部手机，他们如何在不同设备之间拥有连贯的身份？我不认为他们有，我不认为你能做到。比如，我认为每次你启动一个新的 WebRTC 连接，它都可以是，没有
way on the other side can I tell, is it the same person or not? Got it. That makes sense. So if you wanted something like that, I mean mean if you wanted to build a product like that let's say you wanted to make a forum over over our over web rtc you'd probably need some type of like central server just to manage the identities otherwise everyone uh every every single every single web browser frame would be a different person oh so the one thing you can do is the web rtc by default generates a new certificate for every connection what you can do
在 rtc 对端连接的构造函数中，你可以传入一个证书，但是你可以为每个连接使用相同的证书，如果你愿意的话。但这说得通。是的。但默认情况下，没有人这样做。就像大多数人所做的那样，他们通过拥有一个中央服务器来建立身份。他们会说，好吧，我会让你启动一个 WebRTC 连接。然后他们把它扔进某个数据库里，说，好吧，这个人就是他们声称的那个人。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，如果你有相同的证书，
is the constructor of the rtc peer connection you can pass in a certificate but um so you could have like a you could have for every connection use the same certificate if you wanted. But it makes sense. Yeah. But by default, no one does. Like most people do, they establish identity by having like a central server. They'll say like, okay, I'm going to have you spin up a WebRTC connection. And then they throw in a database somewhere and say, okay, this person is who they claim to be. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, if you had the same certificate,
要同步证书，你需要一个中央服务。所以你需要 Dropbox 或类似的东西。所以如果你有这个限制，你还不如有一个服务器，正如你所说，它只是收集大量的证书并说，这全都是鲍勃·史密斯。是的。
to synchronize the certificates, you'd need a central service. So you'd need Dropbox or something. So if you have that restriction, you might as well have a server that, as you said, just collects a lot of certificates and says, this is all Bob Smith. Yeah.
酷。这太棒了。那么人们用 WebRTC 构建了一些什么异国情调的东西，真的让你说，哇，我没想到这一点，我没想过那个。所以对我来说最近真正有趣的是
Cool. This is awesome. So what are some exotic things that people have built with WebRTC that really kind of made you say, wow, I didn't think that, I hadn't thought about that. So I think the ones that are really interesting to me recently
游戏流式传输的故事。比如 Stadi 是，如何在亚秒级时间内将内容从一台机器传输到另一台机器？所以这是游戏流式传输，游戏流式传输的故事，比如 study 是，如何在亚秒级时间内将内容从一台机器传输到另一台机器？所以这是游戏流式传输，这是嗯分享你的桌面和类似的其他东西，另一个是，所以有那一块，我如何将内容从 a 传输到 b，另一个是，我看到越来越多这些嵌入式设备的通信。所以，WebRTC 内置了一个叫做 MDNS 的东西。如果你坐在你的苹果电脑前
is the game streaming story. So like Stadi is, how do I get content from one machine to another in sub-second time? So this is game streaming the game streaming story so like study is how do i get content from one machine to another in sub second time so this is game streaming this is um sharing your desktop and other stuff like that and then the other so there's kind of that area how do i share content from a to b the other one is i'm seeing a lot more of these embedded devices communication. So, WebRTC has something built into it called MDNS. And if you sit down on your Apple computer
并点击“我的网络邻居”，你会看到该网络中的其他计算机。其工作原理是通过多播。所以，它会发送一条小的 UDP 消息，并发送一个查询。它会说，好吧，我是你网络的新成员。这里的所有其他人，请回复我。然后所有这些计算机都会直接回复你。
and you click on My Network Places, you'll see other computers in that network. And the way that works is via multicast. So, it'll send out a little UDP message, and it will send out a query. And it'll say, okay, I'm new to your network. Everyone else who's here, respond to me. And then all of those computers respond directly to you.
这是一种让你 ping 所有人的方法。所以我看到了——所以你能深入探讨一下吗——因为我实际上不知道这个。比如，什么是多播？比如，这实际上是如何工作的？这有什么用？所以你要做的是订阅一个多播组。所以在 Go 中，API 非常简单，你订阅一个组，然后从一个组读取或向一个组写入。
It's a way for you to ping everyone. And so I saw— So can you dive in a little bit on—because I don't actually know this. Like, what is Multicast? Like, how does that actually work? What does that do? So what you do is you subscribe to a multicast group. So in Go, the API is as simple as you subscribe to a group and then you read from a group or you write to a group.
所以当我启动时，我订阅了 2240099。它只是那些组之一。你可以根据需要在不同的 IP 地址上拥有任意数量的组。所以一旦你订阅了一个组，如果任何人向该组写入，每个人都会收到消息。这很酷的一点是，你不需要提前知道其他人的 IP 地址。基本上你是在说，好吧，如果这个网络中的任何人向这个多播组写入，我就会收到它。所以如果你想将消息从一对多或多对多广播，这非常棒。所以这是一对多，但在整个互联网上，比如任何使用 WebRTC 的人？
So when I start up, I subscribe to 2240099. And it's just one of those groups. And you can have as many as you want on different IP addresses that you want. And so once you're subscribed to a group, if anyone writes that group, everyone gets the message. And what's cool about this is you don't have to know other people's IP addresses ahead of time. Like basically you're saying, okay, if anyone in this network writes to this multicast group, I'll receive it. So it's great for if you want to broadcast a message from one-to-many or many-to-many. And so this is one-to-many but over the whole internet, like anyone who's using WebRTC?
哦，不。不幸的是，它仅在同一个局域网中。哦，天哪。哦，我明白了。在同一个局域网中。哦，天哪。哦，我明白了。所以发生的事情是你的交换机或路由器或任何东西只是有连接到它的所有人的列表。然后当你以某种方式向它发送东西时，它会把这个给其他人。
Oh, no. Unfortunately, it's only in the same LAN. Oh, God. Oh, I see. in the same LAN. Oh, God. Oh, I see. So what's happening is your switch or your router or whatever just has a list of all the people connected to it. And then when you send something to it in a certain way, it gives this to everybody else.
是的，完全正确。所以这很酷，因为你不再需要中央服务器了。如果你有两台笔记本电脑在同一个网络中，它们都可以命中多播并相互找到，而不需要任何人居中斡旋。这与 stun 的想法有什么关系？因为现在这两台计算机都将尝试连接某些谷歌服务器，这几乎就像数据包必须出去然后回来一样。所以当 WebRTC 启动时，即建立连接的第一部分，你列一个清单，好吧，这是我的私有 IP，这是我的 stun IP，这是我的 turn IP。
Yeah, exactly. And so this is cool because you don't have to have a central server anymore. If you have two laptops that are in the same network, they can both hit the multicast and then find each other without anyone having to broker in the middle of them. How does that play with the stun idea? Because now both these computers will try to reach some Google server and it's almost like the packet has to go out and then come back. So when WebRTC starts up, that first part of establishing connectivity, you make a list of, okay, here is my private IP, here is my stun IP, and here is my turn IP.
并在所有这些IP上建立连接。但随后 ICE 会评估哪个实际上最适合使用。所以它们每个都有相关的成本。所以我会说直接连接的成本为零。所以如果你能有一些成本为零的东西，WebRTC 会更喜欢它。假设你有多个公共 IP 地址，你可以比较它们中的每一个，看看哪一个最好用，
And you establish connectivity over all of them. But then ICE evaluates which is actually the best to use. So each of them have an associated cost. So I would say direct connectivity is like a cost of zero. So if you can have something with a cost of zero, WebRTC is going to prefer that. And let's say you have multiple public IP addresses, you could compare each of them and see which is the best one to use,
比如哪个延迟最低，哪个丢包率最低，诸如此类。因此，ICE 允许你对我的两个对端之间哪条才是真正的最佳路径做出明智的决定。哦，哇。这很有趣。所以它偶尔会保持更新吗？换句话说，ICE 会说，好吧，每一个，你知道，每第 10 个数据包我将通过三个不同的通道发送它，而且几乎就像机器里的跟踪路由一样，对吧？我要拿走每第 10 个数据包，我将通过所有这些不同的方式发送它，然后在另一端，你知道我知道这是每第 10 个数据包，我会得到
like which has the lowest latency, which has the least packet loss, and stuff like that. So ICE allows you to make intelligent decisions over which is actually the best pathway between my two peers. Oh, wow. That's interesting. So is it occasionally, does it keep that up to date? So in other words, does ICE say, okay, every okay every you know 10th packet i'm going to send it on three different channels and uh almost like a like a trace around in a machine gun right i'm going to take every 10th packet i'm going to send it on all these different ways and then on the other end uh what you know i know that this is every 10th packet i'm going to get
你知道 10 次不同的机会，我会测量哪一个是最快的。是的，所以 WebRTC，他们有重新协商的概念。发起呼叫的人选择你将通过哪个对端进行通信。你向另一端发送，我选择或我指定这个 IP 地址，就像我的源 IP 地址到你的目标 IP 地址一样。并且在任何时候，你都可以重新指定并选择一堆新的本地和远程候选者。所以，是的，就像你说的，就像一个跟踪路由一样，在任何时候，它都可以切换配对。
you know 10 different times and i'm going to get 10 different times, and I'm going to measure which one was the fastest. Yeah, so WebRTC, they have this concept of renegotiation. So the person that started the call chooses which peer you're going to communicate over. You send to the other side, I select or I nominate this IP address, like my source IP address to your destination IP address. And at any time, you can re-nominate and choose a new pair of local and remote candidates. And so, yeah, so like you said, like a tracer round, at any time, it could switch which pairs.
我们经常看到这种情况的地方是人们在移动设备之间移动，或者他们在手机上并在移动设备之间移动，或者他们通过 4G 移动到他们的运营商。如果你正在进行 WebRTC 呼叫，并且你从房子里面走到外面，它实际上会切换，因为突然之间你所在的 IP 地址不再有效了。所以它会动态重新指定。哇，这是一个真正的统计挑战，对吧？是的。我认为这是最有趣的事情。
And where we see this a lot is where people move between mobile and either like they're on their cell phone and they move between mobile or they move over to their provider via 4G. So if you're on a WebRTC call and you go from inside your house to outside, it'll actually switch because all of a sudden the IP address you're on isn't valid anymore. And so it'll re-nominate on the fly. Wow, that's a real statistical challenge, right? Yeah. And I think that's the fun thing.
这就是我喜欢 WebRTC 的原因。我鼓励更多的人加入进来，因为你有网络挑战，你有视频压缩和视频编码挑战，你有密码学挑战。对我和我来说，这是你现在能去的最有趣的地方，是的，这太棒了，而且你知道，我觉得，嗯，我认为我们这里会发生某种寒武纪大爆炸，对吧？我的意思是，网络 rtc 上可能会有一个论坛，
That's why I love WebRTC. And I encourage more people to get into it because you have networking challenges, you have video compression and video coding challenges, you have cryptography challenges. This is, for me the most fun place you can be right now yeah that's awesome and you know i feel as if um i i think we're going to get this sort of cambrian explosion here right i mean like there could be a forum
实际上我看到了某样东西，我想它叫 zero net，或者可能是 zero rpc，但它是你在电脑上运行服务器的东西。我假设它是一个 WebRTC 服务器。然后你实际上将浏览器指向 localhost，那里有一整串你可以访问的网站列表。当你访问这些网站中的任何一个时，它都是从其他对端获取所有内容的。我喜欢那个。
over web rtc actually i saw something um i think it was called zero net or maybe it was zero rpc but it was something where you run a server on your computer. I'm assuming it's a WebRTC server. And then you actually point your browser to localhost and there's a whole list full of websites you can visit. And when you go to any of these websites, it's getting all of it from other peers. I love that.
对我来说最重要的两个是 IPFS。因此，我们不使用我们传统习惯的互联网，而是对其进行分发，以便每个人都托管他们有兴趣分享的任何内容。你可以通过 WebRTC 完成所有这些。然后 Tor 有他们的 Snowflake 项目，你可以通过 WebRTC 进行审查绕过。如果世界上其他人无法访问网站，他们会去找你并要求你替他们访问。他们会通过 WebRTC 发出该请求，这开启了一堆有趣的事情。是的，所以告诉人们什么是 IPFS。
And then the two big ones for me are IPFS. So instead of using the internet via what we're traditionally used to, it's distributed so that each person will host whatever content they're interested in sharing. And you can do all that via WebRTC. And then Tor has their Snowflake project where you can do censorship circumvention via WebRTC. So if another person out in the world can't access a website, they'll go to you and request that you access it for them. And they'll make that request via WebRTC, which opens up a bunch of interesting things. Yeah, so tell people what IPFS is.
其实，我不知道这个首字母缩写，但哦，星际文件系统，好吧，我相信，我相信，但我可能也会弄砸，但它是这个概念，而不是，嗯，我想经典的假设，假设你去一个网站，它是由某人托管的一些小众网站，你喜欢他们的内容。然后你再去，它不见了，因为互联网不是去中心化的。当内容消失时，它就永远消失了。但有了 IPFS，这个想法是互联网现在应该像一个对端云。所以如果你访问一个网站，你应该下载它并在本地存储它。然后当其他人去访问那个网站时，如果它不见了，他们不会从原作者那里下载，而是会从你这里下载。
Actually, I don't know the acronym but oh the internet protocol file system okay i believe i believe but i'll probably mess it up as well but um it's the uh it's the idea that instead of um well i guess the the classical problem let's say you go to a website and it's like some niche website that's hosted by someone and you love their content. And then you go later and it's gone because the Internet isn't decentralized. When that content's gone, it's gone forever. But with IPFS, the idea is that the Internet should now be like a cloud of peers. So if you visit a website, you should download it and store it locally. And then when someone else goes to visit that website, if it's gone, they would instead of downloading it from the original person, they would download it from you.
哦，我明白了。是的。所以这就像我大大简化后的版本。这是一个了不起的项目。他们构建了所有这些，就像他们解决了这些技术上极具挑战性的问题一样，作为一个团队，我跟他们交谈过几次，他们是一个非常友好、支持度很高的团队，他们使用 pion，并且在整个过程中他们都超级友善，他们解释了他们需要什么以及什么需要改进，我对他们赞不绝口
Oh, I see. Yeah. So that's like my really reduced ad nausea, like reduced greatly. It's an amazing project. They've built all these, like they've solved these really technologically challenging problems and as a group um i've talked to them a few times and they're such a nice like supportive group they've been they use pion and like during the whole process they were super nice and they explained like what they needed and what needed to be better i couldn't say enough nice things
，但这就是要点，我只会去 ipfs.io，他们有一个很好的营销网站来解释他们在尝试做什么，酷，这太棒了，所以这就是要点。我只会去 ipfs.io，他们有一个很好的营销网站来解释他们在尝试做什么。酷。这太棒了。所以它是一个网页上的文件系统。你可以创建内容，然后我想如果人们索要你的内容，最初你将是给他们内容的人。但随着它越来越受欢迎，会产生一种网络效应，最终其他人也会帮助你。是的，它大大降低了带宽成本。它使扩展变得更容易，因为如果，比方说，有人下载它，
about them but that's but that's the gist of it and i would just go to ipfs.io and they have a great marketing site to explain like what they're trying to do cool that's awesome soist of it. And I would just go to ipfs.io, and they have a great marketing site to explain what they're trying to do. Cool. That's awesome. So it's a file system over the web. You can create content, and then I guess if people ask for your content, initially you'll be the one giving it to them. But as it gets more and more popular, there's a sort of network effect, and eventually other people will be helping you. Yeah, and it greatly reduces bandwidth costs. It makes it easier to scale because if, let's say, that someone downloads it,
你有一个在东海岸的服务器，但它在日本非常受欢迎。人们不应该为了下载你的网站而连接整个世界。他们应该只在同一地区的对端之间共享它。是的，我们应该把播客放在 IPFS 上。上面应该有一个播客应用程序。是的。我认为它只是开启了所有这些新的可能性，
you have one server that's on the East Coast, but it's really popular in Japan. People shouldn't have to be connecting over the entire world to download your website. They should just be sharing it among their peers in the same region. Yeah, we should have the podcast on IPFS. There should be a podcasting app on that. Yeah. And I think it just opens up all these new possibilities,
特别是当你谈论点对点时，比如举行会议、玩游戏。它开启了太多酷炫的事情。在任何情况下延迟都会比通过服务器更差吗？或者这有点像三角不等式类型的东西？这很难回答，因为在协议级别，我不认为有任何理由说明两者
especially when you're talking peer-to-peer, like having conferencing, having games. It opens up so many cool things. Is there any case where the latency would be worse than going through a server? Or is that sort of like a triangle inequality type thing? I think that's tough to answer because at a protocol level, I don't think there's any reason why either
应该更快或更慢，但我认为这只取决于有什么服务器，如果你在做客户端服务器，你有什么服务器可用以及它们有多近。如果你在做点对点，比如你合作的对端的质量是什么样的，诸如此类。明白了。是的，这说得通。无论哪种方式，我想你总是可以测量的。如果你测到高延迟，你可以尝试让你的应用程序适应这种情况，是的，我认为还有很多其他问题会起作用，
should be faster or slower, but I think it just depends on what servers, if you're doing client server, what servers you have available and like how close they are. And if you're doing a peer to peer, like what's the quality of the peers you're working with and stuff like that. Got it. Yeah, that makes sense. Either way, I guess you could always measure. If you're measuring high latency you can try to adapt your application to that yeah and I think there's also a lot of other problems that go into
所以如果可以的话，你可能有超低的延迟，但有很多丢包，所以你可能会有很多抖动之类的东西，有很多问题会牵涉其中，这就是进入视频领域最有趣的部分，即在这些情况下选择哪些视频帧最重要，比如
play so if you can you might have super low latency but a lot of packet loss so you might have a lot of jitter and stuff like that there's a lot of problems that go into it and that's what's the fun part of when you get into the video area is choosing what video frames are the most important in those scenarios like
如果你有很多丢包，也许以某种方式对视频进行编码是没有意义的，诸如此类，是的，这完全说得通，是的，我的意思是，如果你有，正如你所说的高丢包率，也许你发送一个较小的，比如你的脸的剪辑或其他什么，然后，你看到这种情况，其中他们拥有的概念是这个抖动缓冲区，如果你有很多丢包，你实际上会在呼叫中引入延迟。所以你会说，好吧，我要增加 400 毫秒的人为延迟，我要给另一端额外的 400 毫秒来重新发送在第一次传输中丢失的数据。好的，这说得通。
do you if you have a lot of packet loss maybe it doesn't make sense to encode the video in a certain way and stuff like that yeah that totally makes sense yeah i mean if you have as you said high packet loss maybe you send a smaller like a cut out of the of your just your face or something yeah and then and you see that where um what they have is that they have a concept of this jitter buffer and if you have a lot a lot of packet loss what you'll actually do is you'll introduce latency into the call. So you say, okay, I'm going to add 400 milliseconds of artificial latency, and I'm going to give that other side that extra 400 milliseconds to resend the data that was lost on the first transmission. Okay, that makes sense.
是的。这就是进行这种点对点 UDP 东西带来的所有额外问题，因为 UDP 数据包在实际协议级别无法保证送达，你必须做出所有这些决定。但与此同时，我认为这种灵活性非常重要，因为也许你真的想要尽可能的最低延迟，但你不想。但是因为但你可以接受一点丢包，比如你可以接受这里和那里有一点绿色的斑点，但你希望某些东西绝对是每时每刻 200 毫秒，是的，这说得通，我确信你也可以，你知道，如果你在数据包上放置增量计数器然后有一些重试机制，我的意思是，基本上你可以在 UDP 之上实现 TCP，你可以重新实现 TCP 部分。是的，这基本上就是你对视频数据包所做的，它们上面有一个序列号。所以对于你发送的每个数据包，都有数据包一、数据包二、数据包三。
Yeah. And that's all these extra problems that come with doing this peer to peer UDP stuff is because UDP packets, there isn't guaranteed delivery at the actual protocol level, you have to make all these decisions. But at the same time, I think this flexibility is really important, because maybe you really want the lowest latency possible, but you don't. But because but you're okay with a little packet lawsuit like you're okay with maybe a little green spots here and there but you want something to be absolutely 200 milliseconds all the time yeah that makes sense i'm sure too you could always um you know if you if you put incremental counters on the packets and then have some retried mechanism i mean well basically you could implement tcp over udp you could just re-implement the TCP part. Yeah, and that's basically what you do is with video packets, they have a sequence number on them. And so for each packet you send, there's packet one, packet two, packet three.
然后你可以检测到，哦，我丢失了数据包二。你向另一端发送一个 NACK 并说，我没有收到数据包二，请重新发送。天哪，WebRTC 会为你处理这个问题，还是需要你自己构建？它会为你处理好一切。你只需要说，我需要可靠的有序传输，它就会让它发生。
And then you can detect, oh, I lost packet two. And you send a NAC to the other side and just say, I didn't get packet two, please resend. God, does WebRTC handle that for you or is that something you would build? It handles it all for you. You could just say, I need reliable order transmission and it just makes it happen.
是的，完全正确。它还为你提供了灵活性，可以说，我需要高达这个百分比的可靠丢包，因为它完全取决于你在做什么。如果你在做一个安全摄像头，也许让它完全可靠并不是那么重要，但你知道，有三秒钟的延迟可能会成为生死攸关的情况，你知道，如果你在看东西，但与此同时，假设你正在做你想做的，
Yeah, exactly. It also gives you the flexibility to say, I need reliable up to this percent of loss because it really depends on what you're doing. If you're doing a security camera um maybe that maybe having it be perfectly reliable isn't that important but you know having a three seconds delay like could be a life or death situation you know if you're like watching stuff but at the same time let's say you're doing you want you know
美好的事情让人们观看你驾驶无人机的广播。像，你不希望，你知道，你美丽的高清风景被小方块破坏。你可以说，好吧，我接受 10 秒的延迟，但我想要零丢包。是的，这说得通。对于像数据这样的东西，你在其之上实现了非常具体的协议，并且你期望每次都得到这个你不会容忍任何丢失的神奇数据包头。是的。然后对于数据，嗯，它也归结为，那里有一堆权衡。人们谈论像，如果你正在，
beautiful things for you know people to watch watch your broadcast of you driving a drone. Like, you don't want, you know, your beautiful HD scenery to be broken up with little blocks. You can say, okay, I'm accepting of 10 seconds of latency, but I want zero packet loss. Yeah, that makes sense. And for something like data, where you have a very specific protocol that you've implemented on top of this, and you're expecting to get this magic packet header every time that you won't tolerate any loss. Yeah. And then with data, um, and it also comes down, there's a bunch of trade-offs there. People talk about like, if you're,
如果你在玩第一人称射击游戏，我不在乎我的，我的玩家三秒钟前在哪里。所以，如果一个数据包到达得很晚，比如如果我只接受最新的序列号，它允许你只更新玩家在其最新状态下的位置，因为你不想让他们在有丢包或延迟时来回跳跃。
if you're playing a first person shooter, I don't care about where my, where my player was three seconds ago. So, so if a packet arrives late, like if I only accept the latest sequence number, and so it allows you to only update where the player was at its latest state because you don't want them jumping back and forth if they have packet loss or latency.
是的，这说得通。为了简单起见，让我们专注于可靠有序的情况。所以大多数人都应该有做一些基础网络的经验。我打开一个 TCP 连接。我可以发送一些 JSON。那个人可以获取 JSON 并对其进行解码和反序列化并做一些有趣的事情。如果他们想用 WebRTC 做到这一点，它是如何工作的？他们将如何做到这一点？
Yeah, that makes sense. So let's just focus on the reliable ordered case to keep it simple. So most people would have experience doing some basic networking. So I open a TCP connection. I can send some JSON. That person can get the JSON and decode it and deserialize it and do some interesting things. If they wanted to do that with WebRTC, how does that work? How would they be able to do that?
所以 WebRTC，你受到的限制是所有东西都是以数据报的形式设置的。对于 TCP，我们习惯了那个数据流。我发出一个请求，这个将保持打开状态直到所有东西都传输完毕。但你在 WebRTC 中没有那种奢侈。所有东西都是分块发送的。所以你会说，好吧，我要发送一条消息，这条消息将只包含这么多的信息。所以我会发送，这些通常限制在 1500 字节左右。
So WebRTC, what you're limited by is that everything is set in datagrams. So with TCP, we're used to that stream of data. I make a post, and this will stay open until everything is transmitted. But you don't have that same luxury with WebRTC. Everything is sent in blocks. So you say, okay, I'm going to send a message, and this message will contain just this amount of information. So I'll send, and those are usually limited to like 1,500 bytes.
所以如果你在发送 JSON，你实际上必须做的是把你的 JSON 切成跨越那 1500 字节的多个块。所以你必须用你的东西的长度除以 1500，然后你发送第一块，第二块，第三块，
And so if you're sending JSON, what you'll actually have to do is you'll have to chunk your JSON into multiple blocks across those 1,500. So you'll have to do the length of your stuff divided by 1,500, and then you send the first block, the second block, the third block,
然后你必须在最后把它们组合起来，然后你对它们进行解码。所以我认为这真的是你会看到的最大区别，那就是东西被分成数据报。它们必须被分成数据报的原因是所有东西都必须通过 UDP 运行，以获得我们之前讨论过的 NAT 穿透等所有功能。是的。我的意思是，即使是对于不知道的人来说的 TCP，你可能认为你一次发送一个字节或者，比方说，一次发送整个文件，但在底层，TCP 做的是同样的事情。是的，但我认为这就是 WebRTC 的魔力，
and then you have to combine them at the end, and then you decode them. So I think that's really the biggest difference that you'll see, is that stuff is split into datagrams. And the reason they have to be split into datagrams is everything has to run over UDP to get the NAT hole punching everything we talked about earlier. Yep. Yeah. I mean, even TCP, for people who don't know, you might think you're sending one byte at a time or, let's say, one entire file at a time, but under the hood, TCP is doing the same thing. Yeah, but I think that's the magic of WebRTC
就是让我们把所有东西剥离一层，给人们构建自己东西的灵活性，因为我知道有时候我拥有的信息用数据报表达得更好，但我却被困在通过 TCP 进行通信。所以每次我发送东西时，我都必须把数据包的长度放进去，然后写数据包的主体，然后是数据包的长度，然后是数据包的主体。
is let's just peel everything back one layer and give people the flexibility to build their things because I know that there's times where I've had information that's better expressed as datagrams, but I was stuck communicating over TCP. So every time I sent something, I had to put the length of the packet, then write the body of the packet, then the length of the packet, then the body of the packet.
所以无论哪种方式都是一种权衡。是的，这完全说得通。然后你必须依靠 TCP 在那里做正确的事情。这就是为什么你必须这样做，TCP 中有一样东西叫纳格算法，有时你必须关闭它。是的，就像你封装任何东西一样，
So it's a trade-off either way. Yeah, that totally makes sense. And then you have to rely on TCP to sort of do the right thing there. And that's why you have to, there's this thing in TCP called Nagel's algorithm, and sometimes you have to turn it off. Yeah, it's like anytime you encapsulate something,
一些复杂性，这可能适用于很多情况，但当它不起作用时，这就非常困难了，因为现在你必须解包那个人的假设，那个人做出的假设。是的，不，我听到很多人抱怨的一个大问题是队头阻塞。所以假设你通过 TCP 发送实时信息，如果流开头的一些信息很慢，它会阻止事情返回，所以，有什么意义呢（如果我发送实时广播，你不想看到两秒钟前发生的事情，但因为 TCP 说所有东西必须按顺序到来，你阻塞了整个事情，只为了让我发送两秒钟前的内容，而你甚至根本不在乎了。 yep yep absolutely 酷，所以让我们谈谈，你知道，你是怎么开始接触，你知道，这个的，你是怎么对 WebRTC 产生热情的？你是怎么进入，你知道，一般的编程的？你的轨迹是什么样的？是的，所以当我在高中毕业，我直接进入了这个领域。
some complexity, that might work for a lot of cases, but then when it doesn't work, it's very difficult because now you have to unpack what that person the assumptions that person made yeah no and the one the big one that i hear a lot of people complaining about is the headline blocking so let's say you're sending live information via tcp um if some of the information at the very beginning of the beginning of the
一些复杂性，这可能适用于很多情况，但当它不管用时，就会非常困难，因为现在你必须去剖析那个人所做的假设。是的，没错，我听到很多人抱怨的一个大问题是队头阻塞。所以，假设你通过 TCP 发送实时信息，如果在最开始的一些信息
stream is slow it'll block things going back so what's the what's the point you know if i'm sending a live broadcast you don't want to see what happened two seconds ago but because tcp says everything must come in order you're blocking the entire thing just so i can send you two seconds ago which you don't even care about anymore yep yep absolutely cool so let's let's talk about, you know, how did you sort of get into, you know, this, like, how did you get passionate about WebRTC? And how did you get into, you know, programming in general? And what's sort of, what's been sort of your trajectory? Yeah, so I, when I started, when I graduated high school, and I went into the field right away.
流速度很慢，它就会阻塞后续内容的传输。所以，这有什么意义呢？如果我正在发送实时广播，你并不想看到两秒钟前发生的事情，但因为 TCP 要求所有内容必须按顺序到达，你却在阻塞整个传输，仅仅为了让我发送你甚至根本不在乎的两秒钟前的内容。是的，完全正确。太好了，那我们来谈谈，你是如何开始接触并热衷于 WebRTC 的？你又是如何走上编程之路的？你的职业轨迹大致是怎样的？好的，所以当我高中毕业时，我立刻就进入了这个领域。
And I worked at a small phone company in my hometown, which I had a lot of fun doing. I worked with Asterisk. And I was doing a lot of PHP and a little bit of C and stuff like that. And really what the big break for me was, and I didn't go to college. The big break for me was going to this thing called the Recurse Center, which is in New York. And I went. And for three months, they said go and go and do whatever you find interesting and learn and the idea is at the end of the program that you're in
我在家乡的一家小型电话公司工作过，那段经历非常有趣。我用过 Asterisk。当时我写了大量的 PHP，还有一点 C 语言之类的东西。对我而言真正的大转折——而且我并没有上过大学——大转折是去了一家叫做 Recurse Center 的机构，它位于纽约。我去了那里。在三个月的时间里，他们说去吧，去探索任何你觉得有趣的事并去学习，这个项目的理念是，在项目结束时，你将
this system forever and you're able to reach out to employers and able to help you and help and grow you to be a better match for employers and when I went there I'd only written php and I wrote an http server in C. And then I also got to work on Firefox a little bit, which was a lot of fun. Wow, cool. Yeah. So and I think that's, that was a big one for me is just figuring out like, how I never really learned how to learn. I think this is like the biggest thing that if I had to impart one lesson upon myself, when I i was 16 would be go figure out
永远融入这个系统，能够联系雇主，他们能够帮助你、支持你并让你成长为更契合雇主需求的人。当我刚去那里时，我只写过 PHP，而我在 C 语言中写了一个 HTTP 服务器。然后我还有机会稍微参与了 Firefox 的开发，这非常有趣。哇，酷。是的。所以我觉得，对我来说最重要的一点就是弄清楚，我以前从未真正学会过如何学习。我想这是最重要的事情，如果我必须把一个教训传授给 16 岁的自己，那就是去弄清楚
how to learn on your own because like computer being in the tech industry like you're going to have to learn forever and find a way to make it fun and find a way to be passionate about it yeah i was watching an interview with peter norvig, who's at least he used to be the director of Google Research. I think he's still at Google in some capacity. But he was saying something I found really interesting, which is there was this new technology that they wanted to use at Google. And they wanted to use it for this specific project. And he started kind of going through and reading the manual and understanding all the different operations.
如何靠自己去学习。因为在科技行业里，你将不得不永远学习下去，并找到让它变得有趣的方法，找到对它充满激情的方法。是的，我当时正在看对 Peter Norvig 的一次采访，他至少曾经是谷歌研究院的院长。我想他现在仍然在谷歌担任某种职务。但他当时说了一件我觉得非常有趣的事，那就是谷歌想要使用一种新技术。他们想把它用在这个特定的项目上。于是他开始翻阅手册，理解各种不同的操作。
I mean, it's equivalent of like going to php.com and just reading every single page of the API. And he got about 10% of the way through and his colleague said, oh, yeah, I'm done. You know, like I finished the thing we set out to do. And he said that was like a really different, it's a modality, it's like a paradigm shift from I think, you know, in the past when, let's say the 90s or even earlier when, you know, the first step was write your own compiler or the first step was, you know,
我的意思是，这就相当于访问 php.com，然后把 API 的每一页都读一遍。他读了大约 10% 的进度，他的同事就说，哦，对了，我搞定了。你知道的，就像我们原定要做的事情我已经完成了。他说这真的非常不同，这是一种模式，这是一种范式转变。我想你知道的，在过去，比方说 90 年代甚至更早的时候，你知道，第一步是编写你自己的编译器，或者第一步是，你知道的，
write your own file or the first step was write your own file system or file handler. That was sort of the mentality is to understand things fully. And now things have become, there's just so much content out there that it's really about, can I get what this is talking about quickly?
编写你自己的文件，或者第一步是编写你自己的文件系统或文件处理器。那种心态是为了彻底理解事物。而现在情况变了，外面有太多的内容，所以关键จริงๆ 就在于，我能快速理解这东西在讲什么吗？
And can I figure out it's going to solve my problem? And what's the minimum that i need to do to you know plug this in reliably and and move on yeah and i and i think for what come what has really come in handy for me is if you deep dive on a couple of those core concepts you find that they they sort of, they, like, they last you forever. So a big one is debugging. So if you can figure out how to, how to use GDB, how to use address sanitizer, and how to, how to use that, all of a sudden, everywhere you go, that concept applies over and over again. Yep. Yep. It's totally true. So I know, and that's really how my career has been. I went from, I worked a job where I wrote Common Lisp. I worked a job where I wrote PHP and C.
我能弄清楚它是否能解决我的问题吗？为了可靠地把这个东西接入并继续前进，我需要做的最低限度是什么？是的，而且我认为对我有用的是，如果你深入钻研几个核心概念，你会发现它们能让你受益终身。其中一个非常重要的就是调试。所以，如果你能弄清楚如何使用 GDB，如何使用地址消毒器（address sanitizer），以及如何使用这些工具，突然之间，无论你走到哪里，这个概念都会一遍又一遍地适用。是的。确实如此。我知道，我的职业生涯就是这样的。我曾经工作过的一个岗位是写 Common Lisp。我工作过的一个岗位是写 PHP 和 C 语言。
I worked a job where I did C++ and JavaScript. Now I'm doing Go and WebRTC. So all over the place. But it's really like once you learn those fundamentals and you learn how to those concepts that apply everywhere, you get to jump in and do really anything. And what got me into WebRTC is I worked at a company that was doing that was in the video space. And then out of that, like afterwards, after I left that, I was like, I really enjoyed it. I wanted to continue being in that area. So I started working on Pyon. And
我做过 C++ 和 JavaScript 的工作。现在我在做 Go 和 WebRTC。所以涉猎非常广泛。但实际上，一旦你掌握了这些基础知识，学会了那些适用于任何地方的概念，你就能纵身跃入并真正胜任任何事情。我接触 WebRTC 的契机是，我在一家从事视频领域的公司工作过。在那之后，离职之后，我想我真的很喜欢它。我想继续留在那个领域。于是我开始开发 Pyon，然后
it wasn't really going anywhere like it was a fun little project i didn't have any big ideas for it but what really inspired me was the community that came on so a big one a big person i want to thank is uh mckeldee backer like he jumped on and he said like i he saw a lot of potential with this can be a library that can go and empower other things like WebTorrent, IPFS. And all that positivity and support that he brought is what really encouraged me. And what I really encourage other people to go and find, like, that's why open source and free software is so great. Because at the end of the day, with your job, projects change, things get canceled. But the nice thing about open source is this is something you go home and work on and build something that you're proud of that is completely decoupled from all of that.
它当时并没有什么进展，只是一个小巧有趣的玩具项目，我也没有什么宏大的想法，但真正激励我的是加入进来的社区。所以我必须感谢的一个重要人物是，呃，麦凯迪·贝克（Mckeldee Backer）——他加入了进来并表示，他看到了这个项目的巨大潜力，它可以成为一个赋能其他事物的库，比如 WebTorrent、IPFS。他带来的所有积极能量和支持才是真正鼓舞我的动力。这也是我真正鼓励其他人去寻找的东西——这就是为什么开源和自由软件如此棒。因为归根结底，在你的工作中，项目会变，项目会被取消。但开源的好处在于，这是你可以回家去开发、去打造让你引以为豪的东西，它与这一切完全解耦。
And that's why I find a lot of joy in it and what's really encouraged me to keep doing it. Yeah, that makes sense i mean one thing that that i'm sure you get a lot is people saying you just went to work you programmed for 10 hours and now you're going to come home and keep doing it again like how do you answer that i think for me it's the sense of community and it's the sense of success that comes with pion and that's why i look forward to coming home and doing it so much because no matter if i had a bad day at work, if I come home, stuff can be going well with Pion. And I think this is like, it's the same with thing like diversify your investments, diversify your time as well. I make sure that I go and exercise three times a week. I make sure to work on Pion. I make sure to go to work. And also like, you know,
这就是我在其中找到很多乐趣的原因，也是真正鼓励我坚持下去的动力。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，有一件事你肯定经常听到，那就是人们说：“你刚去上班，编程了 10 个小时，现在你要回家继续干。”你如何回答这个问题？我想对我和来说，是那种社区感，以及伴随 Pyon 而来的成功感。这就是为什么我那么期待回家去搞这个，因为无论我在工作中有多么糟糕的一天，如果我回到家，Pyon 的进展顺利，一切就可以进行得很顺利。我认为这和分散投资是一样的，也要分散你的时间。我确保自己一周锻炼三次。我确保抽出时间开发 Pyon。我确保去上班。而且，你知道，
I'm married. We go and do things a lot. We go and travel. It's like don't invest all your time into one thing because when that one thing is going wrong, like if work is stressful, it's going to tear down your entire life. That's why I encourage people to do a bunch of different things because you'll notice that it will last you a lot longer.
我已经结婚了。我们经常一起做很多事情。我们去旅行。这就像是不要把所有时间都投资在一件事上，因为当那一件事出错时——比如工作压力很大——它会彻底摧毁你的整个生活。这就是为什么我鼓励人们去做各种不同的事情，因为你会发现这样能让你坚持得更久。
Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, it's really inspiring. Yeah, I think along those lines one issue that i see is a lot of folks um it's very hard to see the stepwise changes in the future right um i think i've i don't know if i've mentioned this on the show but um uh they did this study it was like a social psychologist. They asked a bunch of 20-year-olds, would you like the same genre of music when you're 30? And they asked a bunch of 30-year-olds,
是的，这说得通。我的意思是，这真的很鼓舞人心。是的，顺着这个思路，我看到的一个问题是，很多人，呃，很难预见未来的阶梯式变化，对吧？呃，我想我不知道我是否在节目中提到过这一点，但，呃，他们做过这样一个研究，是一群社会心理学家。他们问了一群 20 岁的人：你 30 岁时还会喜欢同一种音乐风格吗？他们问了一群 30 岁的人：
would you like the same genre? Do you like the same genre now as you did when you were 20? And the answers were completely different. So a lot of the 20-year-olds felt like they would like the same genre. If they're into, let's say, country or rock or something, they'd still like metal when they're 30 and almost all the 30 year olds said nope you know i changed my style and uh and they repeated this 10 years later just to make sure that maybe the music in the 90s was really good or something they repeated it 10 years later
你喜欢同一种风格吗？你现在喜欢的音乐风格和 20 岁时一样吗？而他们的回答完全不同。因此，许多 20 岁的人觉得他们会喜欢同一种风格。如果他们喜欢，比方说乡村音乐、摇滚乐或其他什么，他们觉得自己在 30 岁时仍然会喜欢金属乐，而几乎所有的 30 岁的人都回答说：不，你知道的，我改变了我的风格，呃——他们 10 年后又重复了这个实验，只是为了确信也许 90 年代的音乐真的很好什么的，他们 10 年后又重复了一遍，
uh you had same people and everything it all showed that people just grossly underestimate these sort of stepwise changes. And so you see a lot of folks who, they say, oh, I'm going to work 50 hours a week. I'm going to work 60, 70. I'm going to work 80 hours a week. And, you know, people, you have to do what you have to do, but never forget those sort of big stepwise changes that can kind of come out of
呃，还是那群人，一切都表明，人们只是严重低估了这种阶梯式的变化。所以你会看到很多人，他们说，哦，我要一周工作 50 个小时。我要工作 60、70 个小时。我要一周工作 80 个小时。而且，你知道，人嘛，你不得不做你必须做的事，但永远不要忘记那些可能凭空出现的重大阶梯式变化，
nowhere and the way to get those big stepwise changes you said is to is to diversify a lot of your interests and to build a brand for yourself um that can't be sort of shadowed behind a company right just like a personal brand that that that is something you enjoy yeah and i think it and for a lot of people it just depends on what your goals and what your passions are in life like i don't think there's any reason that you know programming can just be a job that you go and do and i know a lot of people that do that and they're very happy um but for me i've always felt this the happiest i've been is when is getting that positive feedback from other people. Like when they tell me, I used your open source project and I was able to build my cool thing.
而正如你所说，获得这些重大阶梯式变化的途径是让你的兴趣多样化，并为自己建立一个品牌，这个品牌不能被湮没在公司背后，对吧？就像一个你所享受的个人品牌。是的，我认为对于很多人来说，这完全取决于你的人生目标和激情所在。我不认为编程只能是一份你不得不去做的日常工作，我知道很多人就是这么做的，他们也非常快乐；但对我来说，我一直觉得我最快乐的时刻是从其他人那里获得积极反馈的时候。比如当他们告诉我：“我用了你的开源项目，然后我成功做出了我那个很酷的东西。”
So you figure out, diversify and then figure out, by doing all these different things, figure out what makes you happy and what lines up that you can work on a lot. And it doesn't even really feel like work yep yep that makes sense oh so how did um how did you overcome some of the adversity and we talked about this a couple of shows ago when we interviewed the pragmatic programmer authors like some of the adversity around uh oh you didn't go to college um you know so your resume you know we're not even going to look at it. How did you sort of deal with that? It sounds like this program that you were in helped a lot
所以你要去摸索，多元化发展，然后通过做所有这些不同的事情，弄清楚是什么让你快乐，什么事情与你的目标契合，从而能够投入大量精力去钻研。甚至都不会觉得那是在工作。是的，这说得通。哦，那么你当年是怎么克服那些逆境的呢？我们在几期节目之前采访《程序员修炼之道》的作者时谈到过这个——比如围绕着诸如“呃，你没有上过大学，所以你的简历，你知道的，我们甚至都不会看一眼”之类的逆境。你当时是怎么处理这个问题的？听起来你参加的这个项目在很大程度上帮了忙，
to get the ball rolling, right? Yeah, so I really credit it to that. Once I went there, they were able to get me into Etsy via the recruiting program. And I give big credit to Etsy as well. They take a big risk on all of these young programmers and say, yeah, you didn't go to college. You don't have a lot of industry experience, but we would love to give you a chance. And they've hired a lot of people
让事情顺利运转起来了，对吧？是的，所以我真的要把这归功于那个项目。我去那里之后，他们通过招聘项目把我送进了 Etsy。我也要大大感谢 Etsy。他们对这些年轻程序员冒了很大的险，并表示：是的，你没上过大学。你没有很多行业经验，但我们很乐意给你一个机会。他们从这个项目中
out of this program. I think for me, another big thing is I really didn't have a traditional career path. Like I worked a lot of, a lot of like different jobs, interesting jobs. And what always got into me is what always got me in was what I had prior knowledge of before. So the job after I went to, um, after I was at Etsy, I got hired because I knew C. And then when I was at that job, I learned, I built, worked on Chromium a little bit. Like I was working at a company that was doing stuff with that. And so the next job I was like, okay, I've worked on Chromium and that, and that got
雇用了许多人。我想对我来说，另一件重要的事情是，我确实没有走传统的职业道路。比如我做过很多很多不同的工作，有趣的工作。而总是能让我入门的是我之前掌握的知识。所以我离开 Etsy 之后的下一份工作，我被录用是因为我懂 C 语言。然后在那份工作中，我学到并构建了、稍微参与了 Chromium 的开发。因为我当时在一家做相关事情的公司工作。所以下一份工作时我想，好吧，我做过 Chromium 开发，而这让我
me in the door. So it's all about, um, like learning those little things and getting you in the door. And most of the time it's not even really relevant. It's, but the person making the decision, you know, they want to see those one little key words. They want to know, oh, you have relevant experience. We'd love to have you. But that relevant experience usually isn't that important. But it's just all about convincing the person that's making that decision. Yeah, that makes sense.
顺利得到了这份工作。所以这一切都在于，呃，学习那些小事情，然后敲开大门。而且大多数时候它甚至不是真的相关。但是做决定的人，你知道的，他们只想看到那些小小的关键词。他们想知道，哦，你有相关的经验。我们很乐意邀请你加入。但那些相关经验通常并没有那么重要。这其实完全在于说服那个做出决定的人。是的，这说得通。
I think there's a bit of a self-fulfilling prophecy, right? But yeah, I think your original point, too, is totally valid. A big part of it is optimism. So, I mean, you made some changes to Chromium. In my case, I've done, let's say, a bit of area in Bayesian statistics. If there's someone looking for a Bayesian statistician, I would probably say I know it. Now, do I actually know it probably not I mean if they really grilled me in an interview I'd probably get hammered but go in with a high degree of optimism especially if you've been
我觉得这里面有点自证预言的意思，对吧？不过是的，我觉得你最初的观点也完全站得住脚。很大一部分原因在于乐观主义。所以，我的意思是，你对 Chromium 做了一些修改。就我而言，比方说，我在贝叶斯统计领域做过一点研究。如果有人在找贝叶斯统计学家，我可能会说我懂。现在，我真的懂吗？可能未必。我的意思是，如果他们在面试中真的狠狠盘问我，我大概会被考个落花流水。但只要带着高度的乐观精神去面试，特别是如果你已经
listening to this show for eight years you've come across a lot of different programming languages and so you know again I'm not saying people should lie on the resume and say they have 20 years of experience or anything like that but it's but i'm saying that uh uh you know people i think if you go in with optimism with an open mind and and you know with a wide breadth of knowledge i think that can go really far yeah and i don't think that and also when people put out these high requirements i don't think they're doing it on purpose, but people also over, overvalue their own knowledge. So when they say I need an expert C++ programmer, they assume they are an expert C++ programmer. The reality is they don't actually know as much as they think they do. And I don't, it's, it's easy
听了这个节目八年，你肯定接触过许多不同的编程语言。所以，再次声明，我并不是说人们应该在简历上撒谎，说自己有 20 年经验之类的，但我的意思是，呃，你知道的，人们，如果你带着乐观的心态、开放的思维，以及（你知道的）广博的知识去面试，我认为这能让你走得很远。是的，我不认为——而且当人们开出这些高要求时，我不认为他们是故意的，但人们也往往会高估自己的知识。所以当他们说我需要一个 C++ 专家程序员时，他们默认自己就是 C++ 专家程序员。现实是，他们其实并没有自己想象的懂得那么多。而且，这很容易
to look at, look at the industry and be like, oh, it's evil because they want all this experience or they want all of this. But I don't think anyone really knows what they're doing. Everyone's sort of just bumbling through. They're trying to find their big project. They're trying to, you know, help their self-esteem by learning programming languages and stuff like that. And like, you know, you just, you have a lot of people that um you know everyone's got their own problem like it's easy to say you know the person at work who's grumpy you know they're they're a mean guy but they've they've probably got things going on behind the scenes you don't know about and it's the same with hiring you know at the end of the day some non-technical is
看着这个行业，然后觉得“哦，它太邪恶了，因为他们要求所有这些经验或所有这些条件”。但我不认为真的有人知道自己在做什么。每个人都只是在跌跌撞撞地摸索。他们试图找到他们的宏大项目，他们试图通过学习编程语言来建立自己的自尊心之类。就像，你知道的，你有很多这样的人，呃，每个人都有自己的问题。比如很容易说工作中的那个脾气暴躁的人，你知道，他是个刻薄的家伙，但他们私底下可能经历着一些你不知道的事情。招聘也是一样，你知道的，归根结底，可能是一个不懂技术的人
probably writing off these requirements and it's a big mess you it's like the i you know fake it till you make it kind of thing i'm still doing that so nice yeah I think uh yeah it's a huge point you know one of the interesting thing we we talked about not show is they actually I posited the question of what would be the the the perfect interview not like a single interview but it's a perfect way to interview and they suggested uh just have the person come on the team for a day um i thought that was really interesting i mean obviously like my mind leapt to all the ways that could go wrong uh you know like nda issues um a person could just flake out i mean all these things but but but uh there is something really powerful about that and it cuts through all of the
在起草这些招聘要求，结果弄得一团糟。这就好像那种“假装直到你真正做到”的心态，我到现在还在这么做，所以挺好的。是的，我觉得，这是一个巨大的观点。你知道，我们在节目中谈到的有趣事情之一是，我实际上提出了这样一个问题：什么是完美的面试？不是指单次面试，而是完美的面试方式。他们建议，只要让候选人加入团队工作一天。我觉得这非常有趣。当然，我的脑海里立刻蹦出了所有可能出错的途径——比如保密协议（NDA）问题，候选人可能突然放鸽子，所有这些问题。但是，但是，这其中确实有一些非常强大的地方，它能切断所有的
garbage like like you know can you solve this this problem that has this trick that they taught in grad school that you have to just you know recurse regurgitate verbatim right yeah no i would i would love to do that the nice thing about open source that makes it really easy if you're running an open source project and you that's that you get paid on for if someone contributes then you can invite them to come on and be like, hey, you've been working on this. You know what you're doing. We'd love to have you. And that's what's really happened with me.
垃圾信息，比如“你能解决这个带有研究生院教过的诡计的问题吗？你只需要（你知道的）原封不动地把它递归背诵出来”。是的，不，我很乐意这么做。开源的一个好处是，如果你在运行一个开源项目，而且你是靠这个获得报酬的，如果有人做出贡献，你就可以邀请他们加入，对他们说：“嘿，你一直在做这个。你知道自己在做什么。我们很乐意邀请你加入。”这正是我身上发生的事情。
It's because I've been involved with open source for six, seven years now. All these Chromium doing C with PHP, like all my jobs have now come out of my open source contributions. Not directly, but just because I can say, go look what I've done. This will prove it for you. Yeah, that's amazing. That's really, really inspiring. I really hope that people who listen to this, you know, we get a ton of questions about, should I do this boot camp? You know, should I go to go back to college and start start a whole new four year degree? And I think this is you
因为我从事开源已经有六、七年了。所有这些用 PHP 写 C 语言的 Chromium 开发经历——我现在的所有的工作都来自于我的开源贡献。不是直接带来的，而是因为我可以告诉别人：“去看看我做过的事。这就能为你证明。”是的，这太棒了。这真的、真的很鼓舞人心。我真的希望那些听节目的听友们——我们收到了大量的问题，比如“我该参加这个训练营吗？”“我是不是该回大学重新开始读一个全新的四年制学位？”而我认为，这实际上
know this is actually a completely different avenue where it's you didn't go into this program um trying to learn C you went into the program it's ultimately I think about um about building connections right so it's it's it's you know here's access to some open source projects i'm assuming they gave you uh like some direction as far as what could be better in these projects and then here's some folks to talk to you and that's i think it's really powerful yeah no and i in i yeah just being it's really just being taught how to learn and being taught how to go help people so they they kind of taught us, okay, you know, show up, talk to the maintainers, offer to help, get involved. And that's the same way I am with
是一个完全不同的途径，你并没有带着学习 C 语言的目的去参加这个项目，你进入这个项目，最终我认为是为了建立人脉，对吧？所以它其实是，你知道的，“这里有一些开源项目的访问权限”，我猜他们会就这些项目里有哪些可以改进的地方给你一些指导，然后这里有一些可以交流的人。我认为这非常强大。是的，不，我——真的只是被教导如何学习，以及被教导如何去帮助别人。所以他们某种程度上教导我们：好的，你知道的，出现，与维护人员交谈，主动提供帮助，参与进来。这也是我对
Pyon now. Like the part of it that makes me the most proud is that we're sitting at like 80 some contributors. And a lot of those are little small over the wall patches. But I love it because I hope that out of that people find the same enthusiasm and find the same opportunities that I've been afforded by, you know, projects before me. And I think that's probably the best part. But it's just figuring out how to be involved and just be optimistic about it. Just go in. Complaining or being in a bad mood doesn't change anything. You know, I see in open source a lot of people like to complain like oh this project stinks
Pyon 的态度。其中最让我感到自豪的部分是，我们现在拥有大约 80 多位贡献者。其中许多只是很小的跨边界补丁（over the wall patches）。但我喜欢它，因为我希望从中能有人找到与我相同的热情，找到我过去通过（你知道的）我之前的项目所获得的那些机会。我想这可能是最好的部分。但这一切都在于弄清楚如何参与进来，并对它保持乐观。直接加入就行。抱怨或情绪糟糕改变不了任何事情。你知道，我看到在开源领域，很多人喜欢抱怨，比如“这个项目太烂了，
because it has this bug blah blah blah and my answer is go fix it go you know yeah you're complaining doesn't change anything about it like you've maybe you've made yourself feel better maybe you've you know you've earned yourself some nerd cred because you can talk bad about a project to your friends but the end of the day nothing changed the world goes on so that's that's what i encourage people just get involved have a little bit of positive impact and the day, nothing changed. The world goes on. So that's what I encourage people. Just get involved, have a little bit of positive impact, and the day will go by a lot faster. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I think, yeah, I really appreciate you kind of opening up and explaining that.
因为它有这个该死的 bug”等等，而我的回答是：去修复它，去，你知道的，是的。你的抱怨改变不了任何关于它的事情——也许你让自己感觉好受了一点了，也许你（你知道的）为你自己赢得了一些极客声誉，因为你可以向朋友们说一个项目的坏话，但归根结底，什么都没改变，世界照常运转。所以这就是我鼓励人们的：参与进来，带来一点点积极的影响，这一天就会过得快得多。是的，这完全说得通。我觉得，是的，我真的很感激你愿意敞开心扉并解释这些。
I think that's just super inspiring to the audience. So we should have a way for them to reach you. So I think what's the best way for people to get started on pion and then also what's a good way to to reach you if people have any questions about the project or anything else so the i think the best way to start is you should check out our project on github so just github.com slash pion you can see the weber t project and all the other libraries that went into building it we also have a twitter account slash pion, you can see the WebRTC project and all the other libraries that went into building it. We also have a Twitter account, underscore pion,
我认为这对于听众来说真的超级鼓舞人心。所以我们应该为他们提供一个联系你的方式。所以我想，开始使用 Pyon 的最佳方式是什么？如果人们对这个项目或其他任何事情有任何疑问，联系你的好方法又是什么？嗯，我认为最好的开始方式是去查看我们在 GitHub 上的项目，也就是 github.com 斜杠 pion。你可以看到 WebRTC 项目以及构建它所涉及的所有其他库。我们还有一个 Twitter 账号，斜杠 pion，你可以看到 WebRTC 项目以及构建它所涉及的所有其他库。我们还有一个 Twitter 账号，下划线 pion，
and then we also have a Slack channel. So if you go to pion dot ly slash slack, or you can just go to the GitHub, and it's on every readme, we have a link to it. We have a community about 350 people that are just talking general WebRTC stuff that interests
然后我们还有一个 Slack 频道。所以如果你访问 pion 点 ly 斜杠 slack，或者你直接访问 GitHub，在每个 README 里面都有一个链接。我们有一个大约 350 人的社区，大家都在讨论他们感兴趣的通用 WebRTC 内容。
them. They're sharing their products. They're sharing things they built that don't use Pyon at all, but I don't really care. I just love building this little supportive community that's interested in these things. So any of those places, I'm always happy to talk. And it doesn't have to be about Pyon. If you have career questions, WebRTC questions, I'm happy that if we can make a little positive impact on everyone. Cool. This was totally awesome. I really appreciate you if we can make a little positive impact on everyone. Cool. This was totally awesome. I really appreciate you, Sean, coming on and explaining that to us. I think we dove really deep. I think we did a good job in giving people more questions than answers because WebRTC, as you might understand now, is very complex, but it's also extraordinarily
他们分享自己的产品。他们分享自己构建的东西，尽管这些东西根本没有用到 Pyon，但我其实并不在意。我只是喜欢建立这个对这些事情感兴趣的小型支持性社区。所以通过这些渠道中的任何一个，我都很高兴与大家交流。而且不一定非得是关于 Pyon 的。如果你有职业问题、WebRTC 的问题，我很高兴我们能对每个人产生一点点积极的影响。酷。这简直太棒了。肖恩，非常感谢你能来并给我们做这些解释。我认为我们进行了非常深入的探讨。我觉得我们做得很好，给人们留下的问题多于答案，因为正如你现在可能已经理解的那样，WebRTC 非常复杂，但它也异常
powerful. And I do think that there is sort of this, you see this curve over and over again, where something is like almost just too hard to use. And that's the time when you want to get in, like you want to get in when it's too hard for 99% of people to use it. You know, like, like, like search engines, social networks, these things now are easy to use and so building your own is really hard right you want to build the thing that's that's hard to develop in so that you could be the first one of the pioneers yeah no i and i i encourage people if you're wanting to get involved in open source or you want to get involved like come work on pion i'd love to have you and it's an. You never know what it can turn into. So yeah, this is the time to be involved.
强大。而且我确实认为，存在着这样一种曲线，你会一遍又一遍地看到它——某种东西几乎就是太难使用了。而这正是你想切入的时机，比如你想在它对 99% 的人来说都太难使用时切入。你知道的，就像搜索引擎、社交网络，这些东西现在很容易使用，所以自己从头构建一个真的很难。对吧？你想要构建那种在开发上很困难的东西，这样你就能成为最早的先驱之一。是的，不，我鼓励大家，如果你想参与开源，或者你想参与进来，就来开发 Pyon 吧，我很乐意欢迎你加入。而且它是一个——你永远不知道它最终会变成什么样。所以，是的，现在就是参与进来的时机。
Cool. Thank you so much. And thank you so much for having me. Yeah. Everyone out there, if you have any questions, you can reach out to Sean. You can check out the GitHub page. And this, actually, this will be, so no, next show will be the last show we do before the end of the year show where we do the raffle. If you're not subscribed on Patreon,
酷。非常感谢。也非常感谢邀请我。好的。各位听众，如果你们有任何问题，可以联系肖恩。你们可以去查看 GitHub 页面。这个，实际上，这将是——所以，下一期节目将是我们在年底抽奖节目之前的最后一期节目。如果你还没有在 Patreon 上订阅，
now would be a good time. As we've said in past years, we don't care if you subscribe in December just to try to snipe the raffle. That's totally fine. But you do want to subscribe because I'm going to draw the names probably beginning of December
现在是个好时机。正如我们在过去几年里所说的那样，我们并不介意你为了参与抽奖而在 12 月才订阅。这完全没问题。但你确实需要订阅，因为我可能会在 12 月初
and that will get thrown into our r to draw the names probably beginning of December. And that will get thrown into our raffle for the end of the year giveaway. Have a good one, guys. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
抽取名字，这些名字将被放进我们的 r（抽奖箱）中，用于年底的赠品抽奖。祝大家过得愉快。开场音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编，但你必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。